good morning everybody woo
okay we've got good audio this morning
uh I'm representative Sue Mullen I am
the chair of this committee and I am
officially opening the interim study
meeting on House Bill 1229
this is a study on whether or not we
need a study as we uh uh
affectionately refer to House Bill 1229
the study of the study bill so uh for
those of you who are joining us for the
first time this is the third time that
we have met
we have been dealing with a number of
food related School meals related uh
bills that came up last session and
taking a peek at whether or not we feel
that there are aspects to those bills
though they were not adopted this past
session whether or not there were
aspects to the bill that warranted
further investigation and ultimately we
will make a recommendation on whether or
not we think legislation is warranted
so prior to today we heard from New
Hampshire hunger Solutions and I think
we may hear from them again today
we heard from the Department of
Education we heard from the American
Heart Association
today we are privileged to have our farm
to school people with us and without any
further ado
I'm going to introduce representative
Alexis Simpson uh who is going to kick
foreign
thank you representative Mullen it's
good to be here with you all again
um yes so I thought that I would start
us off by
um reminding people of what was behind
the bill that we proposed on the farm to
school reimbursement policy Bill and
then
um open it up to insights and
information from the folks behind me who
are all stakeholders in this in this
policy
so last winter we brought to you a farm
to school reimbursement bill
um this kind of program as you know
would increase healthy local food
options available to New Hampshire
school children it would help us build
supply chain resiliency and support our
New Hampshire economy by increasing the
amount of food New Hampshire schools
purchased from local farms so since last
spring we have continued to work with
stakeholders to discuss the best ways to
move forward with this idea we've also
gathered more information from around
the country about what makes a good
program work and to identify solutions
to some of the challenges that we have
seen some of which came up in our
conversation with this committee
previously
we have a strong Farm to school uh
program in some districts in this stage
with state which is good news but we
want all children to have access to
Healthy nutrition nutritious local food
and some of the experts and Advocates
here from the Child Nutrition community
and other stakeholders will talk more
about the importance of Child Nutrition
and how this bill fits into that they'll
be able to answer technical questions
that you have about this Farm to school
program about Child Nutrition and about
the local food system
so we're looking forward to hearing some
of your questions or all of your
questions and incorporating
um that feedback but we also want to say
that we've spoken in some detail with
folks from the Department of Education
and the Department of Agriculture and
already see some areas where we could
simplify what we've been working on
which is great news and we'll keep those
conversations moving forward as well
um
we have already taken I don't do would
you like me to talk about some of those
things those specifics great
um so we've already taken under
advisement the feedback uh from the
Department of
um agriculture that the tiered system
might be difficult to administer
especially at the beginning of this uh
of this
um
of instituting this policy so I don't
know if you remember speaking of details
I know how many bills you all saw and
thank you for that work but I'm not
going to ask you to remember those
details let me real quickly say we had
talked about a tiered system of
reimbursement where we would
reimbursement a New Hampshire farms at a
higher level than we would reimburse
Farms outside of New Hampshire that were
providing local food
um I do want to say that there's been
years worth of collaboration among our
states in the region to develop Regional
Food Systems and to approach food
security and resiliency from a regional
perspective because in New Hampshire we
don't produce a big percentage of our
own products this is the reason we
thought of that tiered system in the
first place however we see the wisdom in
sourcing all products for the farm to
school reimbursement program from New
Hampshire Farms Fishers and producers so
we'd like to see if we can make that
work and we also hope that this will
dovetail with the Department of
agriculture's work to build up and
strengthen our New Hampshire Food
Systems infrastructure
are um it's important to note here that
our at the beginning of the school year
our food service directors are still
facing some supply chain issues so that
problem has not completely gone away
and then
um there was another piece of the bill
about how the reimbursements would take
place and so we've begun the
conversation with the Department of
Education about how we could make that
easiest for them
um and ha and do it in a way that fits
with the way they already reimburse for
School meals
um in a continuous process instead of
having a specific date every month that
receipts are due so I you know I don't
know how those details would shape out
exactly but just to know we're working
um for what will be easiest for the
Department of Education to make this
program work should the legislature
decide that this policy
um is a good one and should you all
decide that this policy is a good one
um so I I want to remind you of one
other piece of this bill which is that
much of our school nutrition money comes
from the federal government but only a
fraction of each dollar goes to
purchasing food itself
um there are labor costs and Equipment
costs and infrastructure costs that are
also part of that
um small amount of money that is paid
for School meals every day
um so as the bill was written last year
two-thirds of the money for the program
would be Federal and the third would be
from the state's general fund we believe
this is a worthwhile investment for the
state you'll hear testimony later about
Child Nutrition but I want to highlight
at the outset that a study from the
Rockefeller Institute tells us that for
every dollar spent on school nutrition
there's a two dollar return on that
investment not only do our children
benefit but this is a fiscally
responsible investment for the people of
so in closing this reimbursement program
would help strengthen New Hampshire's
agriculture sector and Regional food
security it will also help New Hampshire
students understand the regional
agricultural Geographic social and
cultural aspects of our food system in
New Hampshire and now I'm eager to well
I'm eager to introduce everyone else but
also if you have questions specifically
this is probably a good time to do that
as well thank you representative
woodcock
thank you Mr chairman thank you
all right it's been a while it's been a
while
come on how are you good morning I just
want to be sure I was clear when you
were speaking about the reduction or
your presumed reduction in the tiered
system that I understand you to say that
the uh
out of state the non-new Hampshire folks
would be basically eliminated to be in
New Hampshire only prices I want to say
that's what we're considering we have
not Fallen um down on that yet because
we have a lot of stakeholders in this
process across the state and they have a
very good sense of what products and how
much of each product we can produce in
order to meet the needs of the program
and so we don't want to
um we don't want to hamstring ourselves
from this from the get-go so we want to
analyze that information first before we
commit to only New Hampshire thank you
representative Ellison thank you madam
chair thanks for your statement being
here I want to just go back to ready at
the end of your statement you talked
about a cost sharing of two-thirds
Federal one-third State yes could you
tell me for my edification what exactly
that is and how much is one-third of the
cost of that which would be the state
share sure so the um
the goal at the beginning of this and
it's you know it's a um as I said where
a lot of folks have been working on this
for a while like how do we increase our
resiliency in New Hampshire right and so
the goal was how do we get ourselves to
have 10 of the food that we buy for
schools to remain in the New Hampshire
economy and we know that when we spend
the local dollar it um a very high
percentage stays in our local economy
and so not to be sending all of our
money across the country
um and and some of that money that we
get to buy food well a lot of it it
comes from the federal government and so
we are trying to redirect 1.2 million uh
dollars
from the federal money that we get for
um
the cash per meal reimbursements okay to
local
farms and where does the one-third share
say come in so that is in order to get
us to ten percent we would be asking uh
another 600 000 from the general funds
all right representative Simpson if you
want to introduce who you've brought
with you that would great definitely so
representative Megan Murray is on the
environment and agriculture committee
and she's been working hard on this bill
as well from that perspective so she has
a couple of things to share with you and
then um Stacy purslow is behind me from
the farm to school program and she's
been doing a lot of um a deep study of
what's going on in other states so she's
bringing some of that new information to
us as well and then we have um one or
two folks from the New Hampshire hunger
Solutions who have been working hard on
this bill in program as well
I think that's all for today
thank you thank you very much yes uh
representative Murray would you like to
uh join
or replace representative Simpson at the
Mike certainly join not replace
um thank you for having me before the
committee my name is uh for the record
Megan Murray I am the deputy ranking
member in environment and Agriculture
and what you have before me uh before
yourselves is a map of the New Hampshire
farm products map
and so this is just a general idea of
what Farms exist within the state of New
Hampshire what's out there and they are
this is a website that has been put
together by the University of New
Hampshire's Cooperative Extension
and if you look at the left hand side of
it as you're going down it breaks them
into categories and we recognize that
not all of these categories are
available as Farms to be
purchased through schools for example
some homesteads may not qualify for
purchase through the school program for
certain reasons
um with that said
um we we truly feel that there is a
network within our farm system Community
whether it's a CSA a CSF it's local
farms it's wholesalers that have the
opportunity to get food into the hands
of kids locally sourced and when we're
talking about nutritional content that
has a relevance to the daily lives of
where kids are in in their communities
as a parent and as a an educator myself
I think that's a wonderful talking point
to have with kids at either the lunch
table or in the classroom or at home and
saying hey what did you get to try today
um and so with that we are really
intentionally working on
creating a network within the farm to
school network that Partnerships with
what's already there in the agricultural
community that is easier for our school
food and nutrition folks to tap into so
with that I'll happily try and answer
any questions but I know that there's
representative
I'm sorry what's up thank you man are
you forgotten house yes
um Megan the
percentage of currently I know that some
of the local farms now participate on in
their own local programs with the local
school systems you know a guesstimation
about what that is
a fairly good question I I don't I I'm
happy to get that data for you but I do
know that
um representative Simpson may have that
information but I will say that in my
own Community School System when there's
an opportunity to purchase apples they
do okay um I do know that uh I had a
conversation with the folks at our
school Services uh food service and
nutrition as well and they are eager to
participate in a program
um like this because they truly do
believe that for example we had a notice
that it was due to some supply chain
issues they weren't able to Source uh
SunButter just recently so I do think
that there are there are true needs to
sort of diversifying what we're talking
about when we're talking about
large-scale food supplies and then we
have our our smaller more Regional Food
Supplies that really are crucial to the
work that we're trying to do here thank
can I can I add real quick absolutely
um that reminds me of something which is
that one of the things that the
Department of Education will be sure to
need in doing this program should it
come about is
um
some technology as well as as staff and
we're you know it's and when we're
looking at other states it's it's not um
clear exactly how much staff they would
need
um part-time to full-time person and not
clear yet but
um
the technology is definitely clear and
some of that technology would help us
have some data that we just don't have
any way to collect at this point so we
don't really have a thorough sense of
that although I'm sure Stacy has some
thank you do you know how much of the
year
um our local produce will be able to
continue supplying food
sure
that's a great question and so obviously
we uh know that in New Hampshire we do
not have year-round farming available to
us we do know that we have other methods
of farming that extend our Seasons
whether it's using uh
um hoops and hoop houses to do that
extension or if it's indoor aquaponics
or Agriculture and there are some other
things that are there and in recognizing
that we do understand that there is not
a hundred percent a year-round Source
but there are also
um that is why we recognize that there
would be a unique mixture between those
representative Ford
thank you manager I thank you for taking
capability of the state to provide
storage and distribution of products now
my experience is not so much in growing
crops in the ground so much as dairy
farming by being Dairy farming
requires immediate cooling storage
hauling them large containers down to a
Dairy which meets the processing that
day and those kinds of imperatives if
you will of that product and I'm sure
there are others for apples and whatever
I just have never raised apples
um
what what is your role in that process
is that something that's that's pushed
off on the
um
so-called delivery system in other words
stores and whatever I just I just wonder
about preserving the product until it's
consumed
and um
this was something that the Food Service
folks and and I had discussed as well
and we have all recognized that there's
been a tremendous growth in Refrigerated
trucking capabilities
um in the delivery services even right
down to the local csas and csfs that can
arrive directly to your doorstep So to
that end much of that infrastructure is
in place already to get the product from
the farmer to the school system or to a
I'll just have that there are
stakeholders that um the Commissioner of
Agriculture and others in his Department
are working with to increase our ability
across the board across the state to
increase the amount of storage we have
because we for a lot of crops whether
cold crop squashes or apples or things
like that um we we could definitely use
more storage
um in every sector not just for the
school nutrition sector so that is
definitely a challenge that the
Department of Agriculture is looking at
and and
um it sounds like has some real
possibilities
um for joint work going forward with the
folks that they're collaborating with
um and and some federal money as well
um but uh we see this as really part of
the whole
part of the whole food system in the
state just also both needing the storage
and increasing the um
the sector entirely like increasing the
um demand in the agriculture sector
which helps
does that is that answer
I was curious about the school end of
this
um currently since a lot of the stuff is
fairly prepared when they get it the the
time and effort to Preparing lunches is
not as great and so the question is when
we're delivering fresh produce
are the school
are the school Cooks if you will set up
thank you for that question
um you have certainly noted a truth
across the state which is that every
school kitchen is different and has
different capabilities and some have
great greater kitchens greater counter
space greater not you know better knives
than other schools have and so right now
those challenges are are largely met
yeah in different ways as well and I
assume that the same would happen with
the farm to school program and sometimes
that is
doing the processing of the let's call
it a fruit or vegetable doing the
processing of the fruit or vegetable at
um at a school that has greater capacity
to do that and maybe the equipment to do
that and then moving it to schools that
have smaller kitchens or you know no
storage space or something like that so
in the immediate future I think it would
be those kinds of fixes that are used
and then in the long-term few future
tried to equip each school to do kind of
I have a question for you ladies
um
in your discussions with the community
or the state at large do you have any
sense of
how many school districts are currently
purchase their products
that is a great question and I'm
wondering representative Mullen if this
might be the time to ask Stacy purslow
from the farm to school program to come
forward she'll have much better
understanding of that than we can see it
in my eyes I could tell all right great
Stacy if you wouldn't mind pushing that
one okay
um
I took some notes on some of the
questions that were already asked and
want to provide some more information
there as well as answer your question
um
so the seasonality of food in New
Hampshire is year round obviously
tomatoes are on their way out but uh
storage crops are coming in Winter
squashes carrots potatoes that can be
procured most of the Year proteins can
be procured mostly year-round
value-added dairy products are there
year round so there's plenty of options
for local food that schools can buy
year-round even though some things
certainly have a shorter season
um
and as Alexis said uh the department of
AG is working to potentially get some
arpa funds that would help support some
of the infrastructure issues that you
had questions about of storage and
transportation
um
I also wanted to mention we also have a
lot of Hydroponics happening in the
state so in the Louden facility there's
a new facility that's going in up in
Berlin that's going to be doing lettuce
as well so there's going to be
year-round availability through new
hydroponic Growers
um
and we also have a food Hub Network so
food Hub is a local business that
Aggregates and distributes local food
um so which is something that hasn't
always been here so they they have a web
presence you can order online you can
see what the Farms have so this would be
the vehicle of how schools can order
food through the various food hubs Three
River Farmers Alliance food connects
Fresh Start Farms Kearsarge food Hub
they all Aggregate and most of them do
distribution as well in in certain
regions of the state so that would be
one of the main vehicles of how schools
uh can and would be purchasing local
food
um as your question that's how many
schools participate in farm to school
purchasing that's a tough one
um the USDA does a USDA Farm to school
census every couple of years
and the last census that was done
um they we didn't have a lot of
participation from the school so it's
voluntary to you know answer a survey
and we didn't have a lot of
participation this past census
so there's really not good data there
and with covid it was you know just been
a couple of very unusual school years
for school Food Service
um so personally for the farm to school
program would hope to get back to doing
my own census this school year to get a
better sense of what what schools are
doing because we have done it in the
past and
um schools by apples it's their number
one food local food that they buy along
with carrots and potatoes and lettuce
and squashes so
um over the years schools have been
doing local purchasing some may only get
local apples but some are doing quite a
bit as much as they can
so it's it's and some are doing nothing
so
um it's a it's a real range of of
activities that the schools are engaged
in
question
so I have a question for you Stacy um
who who does it well
is it Maine is it Vermont is it Idaho is
uh is there a state out there that is
sort of pioneering this or uh pioneered
it 20 years ago when we just are
catching up
yeah 20 years ago it really wasn't a
thing
um
Farm to school as a national thing came
into being in around 2004 and that's
when the New Hampshire Farm to school
program started
um and it was New Hampshire Farm to
school started with a grant and there
was a some efforts on the Seacoast to
get local food into schools and worked
with one farmer one conventional
distributor and a handful of schools on
the Seacoast to move to you know move
local food in that way
it's a challenge because the school
lunch program is the same across the
country on how it functions
um and there's a lot of requirements and
guidelines
of
how you have to go about purchasing food
and nutrition requirements related to
school meal programs and the amount of
funding that's available to support
Foods food purchasing so
there are good examples across the
country there's I didn't say there's any
one state that's doing it better I think
some states have more infrastructure for
Farm to school than other states so like
Vermont has
their organic farming Association has a
farm to school position their Department
of Agriculture has a farm to school
position they have several non-profit
organizations dedicated to farm to
school so there's more resources and
infrastructure in Vermont to do the kind
of work and of course Vermont has a lot
more farms in New Hampshire
um
so they do a pretty good job there
but we do have some pockets of good food
purchasing
um
I know last earlier this year we heard
some testimony from the Exeter school
district and they've been engaged in
farm to school for many years
I work closely with the oyster School
District because I'm based at UNH and
they're right there and
um they were given through a warrant
article extra money every year to just
to buy local food for their School meals
program because they know the value that
it it is for the kids and for the
agricultural community over there so
that's sort of an exception
that the community decided to give the
school Food Service money just to buy
local food so that's kind of what we
hope this bill would do
incentivize schools so they can get
local fresh
more nutritious food support the local
agricultural economy and support the
farms in their Community if they can
um
sure
I think you're off the hook okay thank
you
representative Simpson can I ask you uh
a question a follow-up question so when
you talked about the technology that
would be necessary for uh getting this
program up and running yeah uh that
technology would be necessary where at
each school and the Department of
Education or just at the Department of
Education just at the department of Ed
yeah okay thank you yeah
all right am I correct that we have New
Hampshire hunger Solutions people who
um
not necessary if you have questions how
about if you have questions for them I
think you're covering the hunger and the
school of nutrition issues broadly yeah
you know in all of these hearings so
maybe if you have specific questions
um for them they would answer them okay
great could we have you uh come up and I
will ask my compatriots here whether or
not they have questions for
foreign
representative Ford
thank you madam chair
thank you for taking our questions my
question is um
system-wide if you will I hear a lot of
discussion about we're interested in
this aspect of it or that aspect hunger
and so forth when I talked and surveyed
the people working in the schools in my
region they basically said we follow the
guidelines that we're given and the
requirements on this for providing
whatever it is for food in the schools
and did not have any record or
much incident apparently of complaints
about their following the prescribed
meal preparation kinds of things so I'm
wondering what from your perspective is
different maybe than they would see it
and are we looking at just sort of where
they can get their food and how you can
prepare it or who has Refrigeration for
storing it in preparation etc etc all
the concomitant expenses of food
preparation that aren't specifically
preparation but
um
yes I just want to make sure that I'm
understanding your question correctly
that you're just wondering like what is
the increased nutritional value of local
food versus following the the guidelines
and ordering from
large distribution companies
I wasn't specifically questioning the
the that part of it it's really just a
question of
how much more Refrigeration do we need
how much more storage when I was a child
we were on a
pretty hard Scrabble Farm but we stored
all the potatoes on the ground under the
house
so when you wanted potatoes one of the
kids got sent under the house to get
potatoes so that can't be happening at a
school I realized and you have
electricity we didn't and you know Rea
hadn't gotten to us yet so it's just
that question of all right what do you
do to keep it unless you're keeping hogs
out behind every school for all the
waste uh it's not getting
processed very efficiently yes so
they're
um
most of the schools will be able to
handle this if they would be ordering
some food instead of other foods from
larger companies so it wouldn't be a
need I don't believe as for additional
storage it would just be replacing what
they're purchasing with more local food
so if they have the opportunity to
purchase local potatoes that were
lightly processed they could purchase
local potatoes or apples or carrots or
cabbage things that are also listed on
there like vocal Harvest of the month
um so being able to to offer something
along those lines on their menu with
these funds because it's not a large
amount of funds that are getting
distributed through this through this
bill
um but it's enough to allow schools the
Equitable opportunity to participate in
purchasing local food for their schools
I'll just give an example I was in a
conversation when I was working with
Stacy on a farm to school project with
um the food service director from
Bedford the food service director from
Exeter and the food service director
from Nashua and the food service
director from Exeter and the food
service director from Bedford had plenty
of funds to be able to purchase local
foods but the food service director from
Nashua even though they're from a larger
School District did not have the same
amount of funds to be able to purchase
local foods and so this bill would
provide an equitable opportunity for
school districts that are from a lower
income areas to be able to purchase
local foods and participate in things
like the Local Harvest of the month
education program
so
um and and I will just add that a lot of
the farm to school grants the federal
grants that are coming through and as
Stacy mentioned the arpa funds they do
help to address
um storage and distribution and any
additional costs that may need to be be
incurred in order to support local food
purchases
yeah
representative Woodcock yeah thank you
Mr and maybe out of line so please stop
me I missed the preceding meeting so and
I don't want to leave everybody else's
time but is it possible for
to get like a two-minute executive
summary of New Hampshire Foods hunger
Solutions what they do the hypothesis
just catch me up yeah New Hampshire
hunger Solutions is an advocacy a
Statewide advocacy organization and we
work to improve participation in federal
nutrition programs
um School meals snap Wick and the child
and adult care feeding program which is
for child care and Senior Care Centers
all right so I have uh I I have just a
curiosity question I I think I'm looking
more for an opinion than a piece of data
here we have received loads of
information
from the Department of Education about
the percentages of kids that qualify for
free and reduced lunches
and in looking through that information
prior to this meeting it looks according
to the doe data like the number of kids
that are eligible for free and reduced
lunch is dropping over time
what I would like to know from New
Hampshire hunger Solutions is whether or
not you think student hunger is dropping
or uh is there some sort of
disconnect between
the the data that we have which is only
as good as the paperwork that we get
right uh so is there a disconnect
between the data and the reality of
student hunger or not
I think there is a disconnect between
the data and or the data and
actual hunger I mean so the most recent
census pulse data tells us that
um 79 000 adults and households in New
Hampshire said that they experienced
food insecurity in the last seven days
370 plus thousand households in New
Hampshire said that they had difficulty
paying for usual household expenses in
the last seven days
um and that's a lot of adults and
households for New Hampshire having a
million people 370
000 is quite a bit of people having a
difficulty paying their bills
um with food service programs in schools
specifically if children don't make it
to breakfast
um
in the morning because most schools
serve breakfast before the bell and not
after the Bell then they miss out on
that opportunity to have breakfast and
they may not have had dinner the day
before and it may be embarrassing to
highlight that they're hungry or
especially as the kids get older and it
becomes more
stigmatizing for a middle school or a
high school student to participate in
programs that are deemed for the poor
kids so I think that we do have an Under
reporting of actual hunger in schools
due to
to stigma due to how programs are
offered and also
um
I would I would say that the pandemic
factors into some of
um the data that we're that we're seeing
that we have lower participation in
school meals because it was harder to
access them during the pandemic when
families were at home and may not have
been able and and parents were still
working and may not have been able to
make it to a certain pickup times
can I add one piece to that as well I
don't know what the data is exactly what
you have in front of you but also
because
um the federal government made lunches
free and accessible to everyone then
there was a period of time where
families didn't have to sign up for
meals and so we there in a sense of the
Gap in data there but also the LA
missing that practice of signing up
every year
um and and being out of that routine
means that it was it's hard to get
everybody who needed to to sign up again
then when it changed back
um to needing to sign up for lunches as
foreign
thank you madam chair this is more of a
comment and I'm not sure it's correct so
I I need to be corrected it seems to me
that what I remember about food stamp
participation in the state that
consistently year after year after year
40 of the people who are eligible for
food stamps do not apply for food stamps
I would suggest that's probably a factor
and you've raised that as a factor in
terms of people applying for eligibility
yeah we do have um low snap
participation and enrollment in our
state
um which we miss about 60 of our
population over the age of 60 who are
eligible but not enrolled
um and we do miss about 17
um children in households who are
eligible for SNAP but not enrolled and
one of the things that
um can help that is the more when we
just
um had passed in the last legislation a
legislative session
um a snap outreach program so our state
is has applied for a snap outreach
program through the federal government
we have a subcontractor that will be
announced eventually once um the the
plan is approved and
um we'll hopefully see more enrollments
and food stamp or SNAP program and
when families are eligible for SNAP
they're directly certified for School
meals which can save a lot of paperwork
and the burden for families
um I can speak for myself when the
packet comes in it takes at least an
hour to sit down and fill out all the
paperwork that's required and then
um the school meals document is
sometimes included in that registration
packet but maybe not always as prominent
so I think it's an issue for families to
know that they if they fill it out it
not only helps their family with free
and reduced meals but it also helps with
other education funding that can help
their school and so changing the message
a little bit for people to say like
they're helping their school district by
applying and participating
is important and it's one of the reasons
why Medicaid direct certification is
also on our agenda of things to talk
about because we know that that will
help to enroll more families without the
burden of paperwork or the stigma of
identifying themselves as being in need
thank you you're welcome
representative Ford
thank you madam chair uh a follow-up
question on that uh process of funding
things when we started this process I
requested some help from UNH contacts
about data that was available and what
they sent us was an international study
and the detail that leaps out to me that
they concluded was don't stop with
breakfast a breakfast only program does
not resolve the child hunger problem you
should school should offer meals
throughout today or at least at lunch
too
is that something you would agree with
as a conclusion
yeah I think you have to have you know
breakfast and lunch served at schools
and in some districts a family dinner
um would be even helpful and that can be
attained through the cacfp program but
just to go back to breakfast New
Hampshire is 47th in the country for
school breakfast participation we miss
about 7 800 students a day who are
eligible to participate but do not
participate in school breakfast and we
leave about 1.5 million federal dollars
on the table because of it so
um we try to change our terminology to
school meal programs because it's more
than just lunch and it's more than just
breakfast it's breakfast and lunch and
we know that those may be the only two
meals a day that a child has access to
yeah
thank you you're welcome representative
woodcock
thank you madam chair and this may not
be the correct time but but Simpson
brought it up so I can take advantage of
that uh we received uh through the good
work of Jennifer IV some information uh
a chart on different costs of things uh
and one of the costs that I do see here
you may have it from the federal we're
talking about the federal participation
last time where it's open to all
the last year right okay
sorry
all right you can have some too okay
thank you hey y'all
um so my question is is there a
reasonable or close or something
possible the guesstimation or good
estimation but what it would cost if we
address the nutritional needs as the
federal government did
for all students for breakfast and lunch
what would the annual cost be for the
state I understand that if we still
receive federal reimbursement funds
proportionately but they saw I was
thinking maybe we had that data from
because of the last year with the the uh
when the federal government actually did
that I mean that's that's a figure I
really like to to pursue because I think
that's the Avenue we need to pursue
do you remember you describe the
question did you miss it no I I no yeah
we I think that I would have to refer to
the Department of Education for that for
that number and we'd have to do a deeper
analysis of the data to have that exact
number
but is that is there yeah is that is
that number available somewhere it can
be it's no I don't unless I'll refer to
Department of Education
um if they have that number but I think
that that number would have to be
calculated okay thank you very much
representative Woodcock just as a
clarification so you're talking about
the
meals for everybody program that took
place during a pandemic exactly I'm not
sure so let's see what the federal
government did during covet right now
obviously we saw the participation rate
be huge because everyone could have it
yeah the the stigma was taken away
because everyone had it yeah and the
food service knew how much money they're
going to get and it was very the
question is if we need to if we have
such a little participation in our
breakfast program it starts the day for
youngsters we have kids who are taking
the lunch program because they may not
be able to sign up and embarrassed and
we know educationally that's what they
need and we have the opportunity to do
it I'm just wondering why we are looking
at a war uh inclusive bill that says
this is what we need to do this is what
it's cost is it worth the investment
yeah just Pro I my point of
clarification with you was not
justifying feeding kids my point of
clarification was that there's a certain
responsibility of the federal government
to participate in the school meals
program so what you're looking for is
what would it cost the state of New
Hampshire
yes if we were to be able if we
instituted that program I understand
it's August manager and understand the
federal government is going to do their
proportional reimbursement as they
normally would for a freemovies okay I
just want to know what our cost would be
for the state so we could know what the
know what the best we can do for our
youngsters just making sure you weren't
trying to live free by uh separating us
from the federal dollars and taking on
our own independent lunch program thank
you representative woodcock so I'm sorry
could I just respond to that I I would
say that there are a lot of
opportunities if we can put all the
right pieces into place as far as
Medicaid direct certification would
identify more students that would be
eligible for
um free and reduced meals that direct
certification process would mean that
more schools would be eligible for
something they call the community
eligibility provision
um which
if a school participates in that can
offer free meals to all their students
and get reimbursed for a certain
percentage of their students based on
there's a lot of formula so not getting
into the weeds of it too much but they
can be reimbursed by the federal
government for feeding more students and
then that usually will bring in more
income for food service programs the
problem is if it's a large school
district or School District that
um has a lot of schools it's it's really
hard to implement and that's why we only
out of 13 schools were eligible for this
program right now in New Hampshire we
only have three that participate in it
um so we would need things in place like
more snap enrollment or Medicaid direct
certification in order to identify more
students who are eligible to offer free
meals to more school districts with the
federal reimbursement and taking the
pressure off the state for that
reimbursement thank you thank you
representative Lucas
I'm curious do you know
do you know why we have such little
participation for breakfast when it's
available
um what we're understanding is that if
breakfast is offered
um before the ball and not after the
Bell then students have to get to school
early to be able to go in and
participate it's often stigmatized as
that is you know when you're getting in
older grades that breakfast is for the
kids who don't have money
um it also if you're thinking about
younger students it's a social time for
them before they go into the classroom
so if their friends are outside hanging
out on the playground playing they're
less likely to go in and have that
breakfast so on what we find the
evidence-based is that if you offer
breakfast after the Bell
um for younger kids that's in the
classroom or grab and go for them to
take back to the classroom for middle
school and high school students as a
second chance breakfast or a grab and go
Second Chance means that during their
morning break period they can go back to
the cafeteria and have breakfast again
um and it and that's those are
evidence-based models used throughout
the country and when those are have been
implemented we've seen huge increases in
participation we did this model in one
school in Dover and saw 40 increase in
breakfast participation when we offered
breakfast after the bell and we only
piloted in fourth grade but saw an
increase throughout the school because
kids were talking about it and breakfast
because there it takes a lot of systems
change within just a school district to
make it happen you have there has to be
um there's quite a few stakeholders in
the decision-making process and so part
of our job at New Hampshire hunger
Solutions is to work with school
districts to find ways to make it happen
but it also means getting the custodial
staff involved teachers involved
principals the superintendents School
nurses parents and students and it's
been a little bit of a challenge during
the pandemic to have all those players
at the table when there's a lot of
staffing issues and other stressors
going on but we do see promise and we
have we actually just hired a Child
Nutrition director who's with us here
today that'll be helping to support that
work around the state thank you welcome
representative Ellison uh thank you for
taking thank you for taking my question
thank you madam chair uh I simply I want
a second what what Steve has said and I
understand the complications that locals
at the local school district level in
terms of implementing a new set of
guidelines or revised guidelines and how
everyone's going to work together if
someone involved in the Medicaid
certification thing I think those of us
on this committee want to know how much
is it going to cost to make sure that
every single kid in school in New
Hampshire gets breakfast and gets lunch
so I I understand the variables and you
know we're if if if if but we want to
know what that number is or what that
number should be that would be helpful
to us and I understand there's a series
of guesses that go into that but I I
would like it to be that specific
okay thank you representative Woodcock
just a follow-up comment to
representative Lucas's question about
why don't we do it one of the reasons we
don't do it is last year a bill to
provide the 30 schools that don't
provide breakfast and voted down that's
all right thank you so much for uh
joining us this morning thank you thank
you all very much are you representative
Simpson you don't have anybody uh no
that's all for us okay all right great
all right in our audience are there uh
any speakers that we have not heard from
yet that would like to address this
issue
excellent thank you very much uh for
your participation this morning
all right so committee members
question
oh I I I I know you're you're always
really here representative Cornell
though uh I understand that you're here
as a guest at this point
um all right so um committee members I
want to refresh your memories that
during the first week of August I sent
you
a document that was created by Jennifer
four
that answered a number of questions that
we had generated at the meeting prior to
this one
um I don't know that everyone has had a
chance to look at it and digest it
but I want to call your attention to it
because if we don't discuss this today
then we will be discussing it at our
next meeting
it is uh basically a body of knowledge
that she was able to pull together
regarding states that have similar
demographics to New Hampshire and what
kinds of things they have implemented or
found to be helpful in addressing
student hunger in those States
so uh
comment first of all were you able to
receive and open the document
yes
[Laughter]
you were you're not good at hiding your
emotions on your face I can see that you
received the document would you like
additional time to go through that
document before we discuss it I guess is
my uh
I I skimmed it I did not fully read it
okay representative for you were you you
okay all right uh Representatives
Woodcock and Hall you did receive the
document Rishi reviewed and don't have
it with me but I'd like to discuss it
when we have the whole committee has
read it okay the whole committee as in
the full commitment oh yeah so we're all
on the same they're all the same basis
of information for the dialogue yeah
okay all right so then um it looks to me
like I'll be giving you a homework
assignment which is basically to review
this document that came in as I said the
first week of July from me so if you
need to go hunt it down again it'll be
under my name
um it has
as it has position and summary
statements from a variety of States
Delaware
Maine Vermont and it also uh goes
through the uh financials of what
happened in the state of Maine because
that has a lot of not only demographic
similarities to New Hampshire but also
population wise weather-wise
and the boilerplate language for any of
the uh
legislation that they passed is in it
is in that document so if you do have
trouble just when you look at it you'll
see that Jennifer Ford's memo and
summary uh is first but then there are
additional documents that you're going
um also representatives Murray and
Simpson if you would like to look at
those documents I'll be happy to forward
them to you as well
yeah just because we don't need to
reinvent the wheel when the wheel is in
the middle of the room all right great
uh uh yeah okay anybody really seriously
anybody that would like to see those
documents I'm happy to provide them if
uh you want to representative Tanner can
I put you in charge of putting a piece
of paper on the end of that table that
uh
collects email addresses of anybody that
would like a copy of this
that's the easiest way to do it I think
all right comments uh questions from the
committee we have another committee
meeting in 25 minutes so we do have time
to discuss anything that you would like
to raise at this point
uh representative Woodcock thank you
just uh can you give me your overview of
a timeline or where you think we're
going or what were we where that closure
point and Implement that type of
property could you mean are we ever
going to stop talking about student
hunger in New Hampshire no
representative Woodcock we're not
um my timeline is this I would like to
call our next meeting for somewhere
around October or 456 somewhere in there
our report on this committee is due on
the 28th and representative Ladd has let
it be known that we will be having a
full Education meeting I believe
somewhere towards the latter part of
October to look at all the interim study
recommendations
so
if any of you have a problem with uh
four five six seven some that that week
prior to Columbus Day
let me know but otherwise I'll be asking
representative Ladd to coordinate with
me so that we don't duplicate efforts
again and schedule ourselves I had to we
had you guys scheduled in two places at
the same time so uh we'll try to avoid
that moving forward I I see that
representative Woodcock as our last
meeting
so yeah so during that meeting we will
consider uh the research from Jennifer
four we can uh look back and discuss any
of the information that we gathered from
New Hampshire hunger Solutions school to
farm uh the doe any any concerns that or
questions anybody has and then at that
point what we will be doing this is it
you know when you're the chair of the
study to have a study uh it's an
interesting motion that needs to be made
I guess we will have to we'll have to
make a motion to either recommend or not
recommend further legislation
but we will not be recommending specific
legislation in other words you don't
have to have an LSR in front of you to
propose what will be deciding as a
committee is whether or not we think the
issue warrants additional legislation
yes sir just finally oh boy to get on
this issue
um is it possible for you to uh uh be
sure to ascertain that number that
representative Ellis and I were looking
for in terms of the I will do so in fact
when I sprinted in here this morning the
first person I spoke to was Jennifer for
because I said to her look I'm telling
you right now I handed Steve Woodcock
this piece of paper and he asked me
three questions right off the top of his
head so uh she has said and also the doe
will uh I'm sure that's so we have the
next that we're on it yeah I will do my
best to uh to get that information thank
you
all right additional comments questions
all right then I am going to adjourn
this meeting we have another meeting in
this room at 10 30 and I'll be back in
my old seat so uh looking forward to it
and the kids home okay
okay I'd like to go ahead and open up
this subcommittee for HP 1680 this is a
bill that deals with uh funding of
Education here in the state of New
Hampshire
and we will
um
what I'd like to do today is that
through the nature of this bill and the
complexity of this bill I'd like to have
uh representative lunal if he would
please just give us from the very top
um a brief synopsis of some of the
critical components that this
legislation would provide and because I
I feel that you know we're looking at
the need for addressing this issue of
funding of Education in the state of New
Hampshire we've been dealing with this
ever since I've been in the house here
and I'm going on this will be my 15th
16th year coming up and it's been a
topic of a discussion that just seems
like you know Groundhog Day and it just
comes and goes around and around and
around and yet we are still hassling out
with some of those major issues and
components that this legislation is
trying to address
there are some issue and points within
it that I think everybody can come up
and say well I don't necessarily agree
with that but I I'd like to try to
get away from that perspective and find
out what do we really have to do to
address some of the issues which we have
here in terms of funding of Education in
the state
um so with that
um I'd like to have uh Dave if you would
please give a you know a brief overview
of of this legislation to get everybody
up to snap
you know be be uh be pleased to do that
actually I was wondering if I could um
if we could if Mel could um maybe um say
a few words just just that would be fine
you know you know and that's what I like
to have brief because I had about an
hour and a half session on Friday with
Bill ardinger and it started out being
only like a 40 minute meeting and it
went and went and went we were at the
trustee meeting together over at UNH
Manchester so try to give the overviews
succinctly if you would I don't mind who
wants to do it nope well Mel's going to
talk a little bit about about some of
the some of it and then I'll I'll sort
of lay out the problems that that this
bill goes uh thank you Mr chair I think
the issue here as you said that school
funding has been on the docket here in
the legislature for a number of years
and the Dilemma that we have
is how do we get a comprehensive look at
this in the past
excuse me in the past we basically have
tinkered
with the formula we've tinkered with the
concepts around it and uh
more recently we had in 2008 Governor
Shaheen had a major committee that
looked at this issue and again they
tinkered around with it in 2018
representative
umberger housed the committee of which
both myself and you were on it as well
as Glenn cordelli was on it and again we
tinkered with it around the issues
around it we've never really looked at
the the core basis of how we provide
Equity around funding
and I think that prompted me to then
introduce the bill that created the
commission
and the commission basically was uh its
charge was to take a deep dive we hadn't
taken a deep dive at this really until
uh since the middle 80s when uh uh we
had
um uh Ogden Blick came in a a consultant
came in and looked at it and made some
recommendations those recommendations
were not followed by the uh by the house
by the legislature and so you come up
with uh Claremont one Claremont 2
Londonderry Dover
Etc
and each time he's not really did have
done the Deep dive this commission and
did that work we worked uh started uh
right in March right when the covets hit
in so we had a lot of Zoom calls uh we
spent a year looking at this in 2020 and
made recommendations I think it's
important to note too that when the
original
formula was created
we basically
did one one thing we looked at the input
part of what it cost the input section
deals basically with well what's the
average teacher salary what's the
benefit packages how many desks are in a
room how many administrators that dealt
with things at the time that the concept
was created we had no we had no data no
metrics that dealt with student
performance
and so if a commission really tried to
look at was not only to look at the
issue of the input model
which we currently have but what might
be another model that would be able to
track
student performance and this is a whole
new concept for us and so that's what we
we looked at David was the chair of this
and I'm going to turn it over to Dave
and let him basically look at the
recommendations that came out of that
that
commission thanks
thank thanks Mel
um yeah and you know I think what what
what Mel's also talking about is um is
the fact that um that you know we we're
we're fortunate I think in 2020 for the
school funding commission to have 10
years worth of data collected by the
department where we could actually
evaluate everything from from a school
district budgets to student outcomes in
every District to how money was being
spent or budgeted in um uh in every
district and uh and uh through a uh a
group of um of Consultants that are
really experts in education funding and
experts in economics they were able to
evaluate that and um and and some facts
dropped out some results dropped out of
that that I think probably were not um
you know are not um you know mysterious
to anybody but uh but in school
districts that have higher incidents
incidents of of poverty student outcomes
were were significantly lower and um and
at the same time
um uh student outcomes were also tended
to be lower in school districts that had
limited access to financial resources
meaning that their property valuations
were much lower than um than than State
average and you know there are there are
combinations of dis there are districts
where where you know where they don't
have both of those to um uh two factors
but those those two factors were
certainly um certainly certainly drove
um student out a drop in student
outcomes lack of access to funding and
high instances of of poverty so um so
although New Hampshire overall has uh
has very strong student outcomes top
five uh in the in the country we're not
seeing that universally across um not
even close to that across school
districts so um
so what house bill 1680 does is
basically responds to the the
information that the school funding
commission learned and uh and develops a
proposed proposes to um uh a a model for
costing uh uh what what it what it would
cost for a school district to educated
students to a to us to a Statewide
outcome uh based on the student and
District characteristics uh how to go
about funding that um uh that that
school every school district's budget
based on their access to local resources
and then the state coming in and making
sure that they can they can get all the
way and an accountability section that
that looks at student outcomes and the
important linkage here in fact more than
half I think probably close to half of
the of the 26-page bill something like
that is actually the accountability
section and that accountability section
is based on student outcomes and the
importance of this
um and and the the I guess the rationale
behind this is that the costing and the
funding is also based on student
outcomes so so there's actually a
rational connection between between how
students are doing and how we go about
uh costing uh uh and and funding our our
local school districts
um the um there's a there's a a third
section to the uh uh to House Bill 1680
which uh which which is actually a bill
that was just had an uh interim study uh
work session in the Ways and Means
Committee and it's called House Bill 504
so that's that's contained in the the
last uh part of house bill 1680. and um
and it looks at uh at a couple of things
that I think are also relevant to uh to
school funding uh that uh that certainly
a significant portion of the of the one
billion dollars that the state of New
Hampshire spends on on public school
district uh school districts comes from
the uh the state property tax the swept
Statewide education property tax and so
um so the the swept currently
incorporates a um a blanket
um uh tax rebate mechanism based on
where you live so if you're in a
property wealthy District than than
essentially you you you get a rebate and
an excess grant for back from the state
currently that's in the 35 million
dollar 40 million dollar range and um
and what that results in it certainly is
property tax relief for for people that
live in those communities but uh but it
also results in an effective uh lower
tax rate for the State Property Tax
which um uh which is on its face
blatantly unconstitutional so household
504 and through its incorporation in
1680 goes about uh goes about correcting
that so that the state property tax will
be collected the same way any other
state uh state taxes uh in this case be
collected locally and then remitted to
the uh to the state and um the second
part is
um the um you know the intent of uh of
property tax relief uh uh should really
be directed to uh to low and moderate
income uh homeowners and not be based on
solely where you uh where you live
regardless of of household income so um
so it it recognizes the importance of a
property tax relief uh uh mechanism and
um and uh and incorporates that actually
builds out our current
um low and moderate income property tax
relief with uh with additional funds and
um uh and and higher levels so that uh
the the benefits would be closer to I
think a thousand dollars uh off property
taxes which for for a lot of low and
moderate income families across the
state would be very meaningful so um so
we're hoping today that that just like
uh chairlad uh said that while the um
well the mechanisms in 1680 may not be
exactly what everybody what everybody
wants and certainly I think require a
substantial uh you know additional
debate that that the um that the
problems that 1680 is directed to that
being student and taxpayer fairness that
being accountability that's tied to to
uh to to funding based on outcome
costing and funding based on outcomes
that that um that districts across the
state don't need a one-size-fits-all uh
funding plan but something that's
reflective of the challenges and the
differences in each school district and
then um and then important changes to uh
to the state property tax and property
tax relief program at the end of the day
it's uh it's a plan that that gets
phased in over a 10-year period so it's
not a drop at all in in the first year
it has a a
transition plan for um uh for for for
local property taxes that that phases
out over uh over a period of of five
years and that would rely on covid money
to uh to do that so I think we've got a
sort of a once in a generation uh maybe
once in a lifetime opportunity to take
advantage of available funds uh for that
and um and and that it um
uh it's worthy of um of further
discussion in the next session so I'm
hoping this committee will uh we'll find
it um uh we'll find it and recommend it
for uh for future legislation just the
as the house weights and Means Committee
just did um unanimously with um with the
state property tax for um for Education
portion of it thanks thank you very much
Dave and and Mel uh are there any
questions from the subcommittee to
either representative or representative
Meyler who just spoke reference the the
high 30 000 view our purpose
okay I I like to move on you you did
mention uh one area and there's a lot to
be discussed here obviously
accountability and student outcomes is
something we want to get into uh however
I understand that there is recently a
letter written by the state senate here
to the governor addressing the issue of
sweat I've not seen that letter and
Senator not not not swept I think this
Medicaid sir okay is that that was that
one for me good yeah we need to have
that yeah Jade you will copy of that
we're running out of time here
and and that was on that and that was
unanimous all 24 23 Senators okay
it's coming in a bipartisan manner he
uh participating in the pilot uh USDA
yeah
Department of Agriculture was doing for
qualifying
school lunch
membership yeah
School meals yeah if we can get a hold
of that letter that would certainly
would be appreciated uh certainly not
something that we espouse too the the
more you know the right now flip through
the free and reduce program we're not
getting all these students that are
eligible signing up as we know in the
high school this big drop off and that
affects everything we do from adequacy
to Career Tech which we've talked about
in the past and the funding from the
federal government we're missing out on
on huge dollars Rick Rick just to
quantify that uh the FY 20 free and
reduced
um and this is the state grant adequacy
grant 86 million dollars FY 22
it goes down to 64 million dollars yeah
that that that's a whole that's a whole
Topic in itself in terms of how schools
are handling that with meals for kids
you know or not providing and it also
then it's a direct uh relationship to
how we're doing everything in the
adequacy there and the funding that's
coming to us and and it even ends up
impacting property taxes yes you had a
question
I did Mr chair it seems please my mind
is not in legislative mode okay I have
to admit that but didn't we have a
proposal that came before the house and
was defeated for that Medicaid
usage
did that happen or am I did and that was
you know the how one read that bill was
how it was interpreted whether in fact
we were giving doe the authority to go
ahead and implement or whether we're
giving them the authority to go and
research and see what it would take to
become a member of that program with
with the USDA but I understand the pilot
program itself is coming to a real close
here
within a month yeah yeah the application
period and that that's a significant uh
issue that we need to address but do we
have time
I mean if the house is defeated that
I guess I'm just confused where it is in
the process is this two different
processes that's the house yeah two two
different things the the
um our our current funding mechanism is
obviously it's important because it's
what's in place right now right and and
it relies heavily on on on the the
um I think paper application student
applications or family applications for
their students to apply for free and
reduce
um uh lunch uh program and so that's
used for two things used for the
students to get free introduced price
lunch but it's also used in the
calculation of the adequacy grant which
has dropped by 20 million dollars just
just because of a change in the free and
reduced lunch right um participation but
the question that I had was more getting
into this pilot program if we had if we
brought that
um up to the house in a bill which we
did you said Mr chair and it was
interpreted in a different way and
defeated
do we have time do we need the
legislators legislations
legislature's approval to get into that
pilot program and have we already denied
that the department the department can
do that the department can do it without
us correct okay thank you very much it's
my understanding that the department can
make application okay uh into whether we
get involved in that program it's a
different issue from the state
perspective of the the department will
they can make the application and get
all that information but for us then
then to get engaged in that as a there's
no financiality issues associated with
Medicaid and all that uh which which
which need to be looked at but it's very
important if we don't go that route then
how do we get a hold of some of the
revenues which we need to get a hold of
and you know it's concerning me as the
school principal years ago I used to
when I had a family come in and request
and be eligible for free or reduced
meals and the elementary children
brought it in and the middle school kids
sort of brought it in and the high
school kids blew it off we were not
gaining revenue for all those kids and
the principal has the option
superintendent of making some exceptions
and saying I'm going to approve this
knowing that the circumstance exists
and I would encourage our Administration
out there in the field that if you get
it in from a family it should be good
for all in that family
and I don't know for Nestle doing that
in all our districts
representative
there's a problem with your assumption
that we can apply and then decide
whether or not to do it I actually had
in my possession the application form
and it specifically says that if you
apply you are guaranteeing that your
state will participate so we have to
know that we are absolutely going to
participate and share all that
information which is confidential and
that information has to be shared as
part of the application or we have to
decide we're not going to but we can't
apply and then decide whether or not to
do it because we are actually in the
application is signing that yes
absolutely we are going to do this
program
thank you
so that's part of the issue and
um that's why we are where we are right
now
unfortunately
so let's get back to this particular
bill here 1680
um and if we could get a hold that
letter J I'd appreciate it
um
that the 1680 has a number of components
within it and I'd like to start off with
just a brief discussion on one of those
components if we may on the the formula
that's and I'd like to see where we
stand as a committee just sort of as
informational on the weighted components
of special education under
differentiated Aid as you recall in that
bill there was a weighted component if
you were eligible for special education
I think it was four point something
times the 4.9 or 4.6 I don't have it in
front of me times the the base adequacy
amount
um we then passed a Amendment last year
remember we were talking about
um I think it was sent off this off my
Senate Bill 420 I believe was the
education extraordinary needs Grant we
added an amendment in which added
another 15 million dollars for two
categories of special education Aid uh
where we uh took the 13 IEPs and there
were three IPS we felt that could be
provided at the cost that we presently
have that was a lot right around two
thousand dollars in differentiated aid
for
for special education and the other 10
categories were basically doubled
and that increased the amount that would
come through a two schools by the amount
of 15 million dollars for the total of
what the significant hunk of money but
that was rejected in past honor
committee unanimously went out of the
house and got killed in finance division
two
I thought well we we brought it up in
committee a conference but that didn't
make it
um it was basically said the letter that
I got back from the chair of division
two now the chair of Finance was this is
a great idea pursue it in next session
well the next session's upon us
and so that's just one of the components
one of the weighted categories within
that and I'm trying to say are we all
still there saying that's a good idea to
be waiting out different categories I'm
not saying that formula is correct I'm
just saying now the the the concept of
doing that yes represent luno yep Rick
thanks I I I support obviously we all
supported it I believe when it came
through this committee when your
Amendment came through the committee
um and uh and I would certainly support
it
um in a in a in in a in a funding as
part of a costing formula as well
um uh as long as we're able to get those
um you know those adms from the um from
the Department I think that was um that
was something that um that we'd had some
some challenges with early on uh in uh
in breaking down to the what 13
different categories yeah I'm gonna pass
to blend those into two categories if
that puts the department into an easier
position where they can provide those
those 80 that ADM information
I think that makes a lot of sense
and I've I've talked to
um doe and Rebecca for for that could
not be here today do that she's at a out
out of uh out of Concord
but the three categories which we have
you'll see there in category a where
developmental delays specific learning
disabilities speech and language
impairments and then everything from
autism through multiple disabilities to
other health impairments was in that
second category
um I don't think necessarily we need be
looking that specifically what goes in
which category I think we need to work
with our department and trying to
ascertain which uh
um
categories within the special ed
differentiated a require a lot more
attention from a staff member in a
school and the costs of course increase
there is some data that I've gathered
National Data where that has been done
and I I've seen it I'll make copies for
everybody on the committee so you can
see it because we're not going to
resolve everything here today and we'll
get that to you
um but I I think as you're saying it's a
component within any formula even if we
stayed with a current formula we need to
modify this area I believe in special
education to more appropriately fund it
this would not fund it to where it needs
to be funded remember the feds are
guaranteed at 40 percent funding from
the national level which has never
occurred it's now what we're down close
to what 16 17 coming down and so it's
that's another thing which we're passing
on kind of like this
mandate to the property taxpayer and uh
and there's no way to avoid that from
happening seeing idea is here and we
can't afford to lose all the other money
Glenda
does this uh thank you does this um
as far as my understanding of special
education there's a pool of money for
special education and depending on uh
what the different schools apply for
that special education uh then it's uh
determine what percentage of their
application is actually funded
um is that is my understanding that
there's there's two pots of money we're
talking about the adequacy money okay
this is not the money which is obligated
to every student that's eligible in this
state so whether you're donor a
non-donor town this is what you get
then you have what we call
special education Aid now catastrophic
AIDS what they used to be called so when
you get three and a half times the
average cost of a student in the state
say the cost is 20 grand to the educate
a student in the state so you go three
times that there'd be sixty thousand
dollars half of the 20 another so be
seventy thousand dollars you have to
spend locally prior to your receiving
any state support at all
then the next component up to 10 times
that average amount the state kicks in a
percentage of that which is I believe
what 80 percent so and then from 10 on
it's you're getting support from the
state for 100 of those kids it means
that this the local districts paying a
huge hunk of money in special education
I'm speaking to a superintendent just
the other day which they had a student
now that's up to the level believe it or
not over four hundred thousand dollars a
year it's a small District they don't
have a backup Reserve or trust fund to
support that and that is where they hit
isn't there a set pool of money though
so for that catastrophic AIDs that
um it's it seemed like they even though
they apply for you know they reach the
70 000 and they apply for it because
it's it's then spread out amongst
everybody in the state that applies for
that same money out of a pool of money
so it kind of is capped they only get a
portion of that um back is that is that
there's two
two answers that we did pass legislation
where districts can get together and
pool into a you know providing a a a
source of Revenue that they contribute
each year so much it's like an insurance
plan
the other idea that we have there we do
have some emergency money available
through the state for these types of
students but it's very very little
and it's basically something which the
school districts can't count on
the the catastrophic Aid is based upon
that formula and that's what you as a
district have to front for the you you
must
yes and it's for the prior year yeah
just like just like just like the
adequacy formula so so I'm hearing from
some schools that you know essentially
they're getting like a 20 20 on the
special ed costs that they have or 30
because
there's a limited there's a limited pot
of money at the state level for special
education that's a very small pot of
money I spoke about
um and that's just based upon uh where
they are towards the end of the year
they can prorate it out to school
districts but that is not that's it's
you know it's minimal marginal yeah
thank you
other questions on the special ad so is
in terms of
having this weighted formula within any
component of funding
we're still on board with this concept
that's good good so we'll move forward
with that
um
Dave do you have anybody here that they
coming and speaking behalf of the bill
um
thanks thanks Rick I I you know didn't
really plan any any particular testimony
on this seeing as this is a work session
but um but again you know I think all of
the a lot of the bills that were were
talking about here well certainly 1680
and I think House Bill 504 are are
really directed at um at problems that
um that I think and I don't think it's a
partisan issue but I think problems that
that people have identified in certain
areas whether that's uh State Property
Tax whether that's school funding I
think there's people on all sides of the
aisle that that recognize that yeah we
got issues in these areas and I think
there's probably some people here that
that can speak to that one thing that we
haven't talked about this morning which
I think is also indicative that that
there's problems in this area or that
there's uh there's a couple of court
cases one that's been filed I think over
two years one that's been recently filed
and um and Zach's Zach um Sheehan is
here and may be able to give a high
level overview of what what those cases
are about and the problems that they've
identified
yeah we can just I'd rather not get into
combat on the Polinsky issue just just
yet we today we can but I'd like to
address some of the specific issues
within the bill like accountability
um
accountability is something which I I
believe that
we really don't have a strong
accountability plan for differentiated
Aid right now I went through last night
and I was looking at the pupil teacher
ratios in all our districts the average
around 17-1
and then I also looked at achievement
scores of kids within the districts and
it's it's a mixed thing where you can
have very very low pupil teacher ratio
and you still have a high percentage of
your students that are in levels one and
two those are the areas on the
assessment which are not performing I
know that's true I I'm looking at uh
represent Woodcock over there and that's
true in Conway
and very much true in Conway where you
have a very high percentage over there
it's close to 70 percent that have that
that are really not faring well yet
Conway does have some kind of a tax
property tax base
um so the and the accountability issue
to me comes at what point does the state
have the authority to come in and say to
local school you're not cutting it
represent Porter so I keep thinking back
to some research
um that was done back when I was
teaching in public schools so that story
somewhat years now since I've been there
believe it or not
um and and it seems to be holding true
from what I've read since then that the
number one predictor of how kids do on
these tests is the education level and
the income level of the parents
so I'm wondering
that so I just want to throw that out
there which might which might have
something to do with what's happening in
Conway that there's a lot of money there
but not necessarily
in the homes of the children that are
being educated
there
so just want to throw that out as a as a
thought so communities like like uh
Hopkinton for example that has one of
the best schools districts in the in the
state they would have a lot they have a
lot of people in the community that are
professionals and have high incomes and
a community like mine which is kind of
blue collar
um we have some you know we're improving
all along all the way but we don't have
as many professionals High income people
in my community so they seem to
um
so what I'm looking for anecdotally it
seems to still be accurate so I'm just
throwing that out there
how we can address that issue when we're
addressing the funding how we can help
those kids
that need it the most
where we can put our funding to help
those kids that need it the most
represent Cordell yeah I was just
wondering if we could take a look at the
accountability section I know that oh
sorry thank you back in practice
um uh you mentioned a significant
portion of the uh the legislation was in
accountability can we take a look at the
accountability sections because you know
they're they're I think our
opportunities there for uh committee
agreement on a number of aspects of that
sure I I actually don't have that
section how many people don't have the
bill in front of you right now
so one two three four five six
Jen is it possible that we could get you
know a good 20 of those down here the
audience may want it as well
here
yeah
you know I what you said representative
Porter regarding that is absolutely true
you look at a town like a Hanover
and and when I looked at the you know
those students in Hanover which were in
the first or second quartile 17 percent
then we're going to look at Rochester
yes
yes okay I'm sorry go ahead Linda so I
just want to caution this uh race
teacher to pupil ratio
um how if you just take the number of
students into school and divide it by
the number of teachers and come out to
the average that it isn't at all a clear
view of what happens in a school there
are some students in special ed for
example who have a teacher for Just Two
pupils or there may be Advanced uh
placement uh courses taught where there
is one teacher for maybe 10 students and
yet there may be uh art music or phys ed
teacher who has 30 students in their
class so it it really isn't reflective
uh people think that they're going to
walk into school and see one teacher
with 17 kids in the class that's not
going to happen and I concur with you
and and uh you know that that's why the
uh areas we don't want to get caught up
in that by
funding districts more money will just
increase maybe that aspect of you know
the lower our teacher pupil teacher
ratio yes that may be good but it may be
also wise not to necessarily put the
money there maybe wise to put it in how
much you're paying the teachers that you
have
um you know right now there's a teacher
shortage we have another committee
looking at that right now and we're
really shallow on the on the sciences
and the maths on the special education
how are we going to get more people and
we're seeing the pipeline out of uh the
university level and the college level
are not delivering the numbers that they
need to deliver to us so why are we
having so few students going in that
direction saying I'm not going to be a
teacher well maybe it's because of it's
hard to live on forty thousand dollars a
year or thirty five thousand dollars a
year first as a person working where I
was on a oil platform out in the catch
back sea getting a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars now big difference
yeah perhaps in Mila
oh thank you Mr chair one of the things
that we did discover uh in our
commission work
uh as it relates to effectiveness of
education is the attrition rate of
teachers
um there's no question that the magic
in a classroom takes place with a
creative teacher
that can work on a sustained basis
and when you have teachers that move in
and out of a district
it interrupts the continuity of the
curriculum as well as administrators I
mean there's no question in my mind that
a pivotal person is that principle
that provides the energy that provides
the vision that provides the leadership
if you may around the curriculum but if
in fact you have and I just take
Pittsfield as an example I mean John
Freeman former superintendent has been
in here several times talking about this
that if you if if Pittsfield it becomes
the farm team for Concord
and you have teachers that are in there
for maybe two or three years and then
they move to to a place where they can
get like ten thousand dollars more
it disenfranchises that curriculum where
you don't have consistency
so one of the things that that I'm
concerned about as well as what we're
looking at in the teacher shortage issue
is how do you retain staff
that knows those students that they're
working with that knows the curriculum
that's there that there's a there's a
Continuum there's a continuance of
continuity of presence of staff that
knows those kids and knows that
curriculum so above and beyond just the
the fiscal aspect of schools
how do we keep teachers in those
buildings that know those kids
and that I think is a huge problem and
that does get back to the issue of
costing again I I hate to come back to
funding of it but it does if you have a
school district that is ten thousand
dollars below a neighboring School
District
and I'm a young teacher that has loans
I've got to pay off and a young family
that maybe I want to think about buying
a house
the issue of funding does become a
critical issue so there's there's got to
be a balance between the funding issue
and the continuity of staff and I again
I want to end emphasis I'm not just
talking about teachers I'm talking about
superintendents at one point in time
Rick you recall
several years back we were we looked at
Claremont and I think Claremont had five
superintendents in six different years
well how does that impact the staff as
it relates to their leadership within
the school district
so so it is a funding issue I agree
but it's Unique to individual
communities you may be living in a
municipality where you can't keep your
local police on board because they're
going down the river 40 miles and
getting a job that's going to add
another 20 grand onto their annual
salary that's happening where I am in
Haverhill they go to Hanover Lebanon and
it's so it's true in not just education
but
everything else we have going on with
the municipal government
and so then it comes down to you know
that the funding that we have in our
formula but are we going to be able to
pick all that or will we have that
difference occurring in our state just
by the natural the way we are
rips and Woodcock and then thank you uh
representative I appreciate the
opportunity uh two points uh anecdotally
as representative four indicated uh
prior to sat is being used as the
standard measure when they're used for
college admissions as the initial
document that that uh demographic of
two-parent educated income was was right
on for you could guarantee all the
scores on the bigger picture that that
uh president Miley to talk about
attrition in Conway it's a that's a a
terrific uh measure because uh the two
schools now representative uh cordelli
lives down in that area with Prospect
mountain and uh I would say on Glenn um
Kingswood thank you thank you
um they are about fifteen thousand
dollars to start higher than Conway and
young teachers they don't have loyalty
to the community yet because they just
got there uh and so they realized that
the two or three years they've signed to
fill the toolbox the science whole thing
and they moved down to a wolf Pro area
on Walton Bowl area for that reason
because they don't really start figured
out of the lifetime so and it is a big
deal because we're training and losing
training and losing so that the people
coming in I have new teachers and new
teachers and we all almost everyone
around this table has been in the
classroom they know it takes a while for
a new teachers not to fill that toolbox
and how to how do you get that youngster
on board with a math class
um so it is that that attrition issue is
a huge issue in student learning and and
uh the retention nutritionist student
learning is is critical and I mean
that's the key if you don't have in the
classroom it doesn't matter how much you
find it
further comments representino
or and then representative Nelson no
thanks very much Mr chair yeah I mean I
think the and and I know we want to you
want to move this into towards a
discussion on on accountability but I
think it's important to recognize right
up front that that what house bill 1680
is proposing it is a comprehensive
change to um to what we call school
funding but it um it's also a
comprehensive change to um to the the
definition of an adequate education and
our current statute says an adequate
education is 50 desks in a classroom and
one principle for every 500 students and
one librarian for every 500 students and
a couple of buses and stuff like that
and um and what 1680 does is changes
that and says an adequate education
offers the opportunity for students to
perform at a Statewide uh outcome level
so was so that's average Statewide
outcome and you know on a national basis
a very a very strong
outcome and um and by setting that
standard and then defining what a
District budget would be so that their
students could perform at a Statewide uh
level and that's going to be different
for every District in the state and the
bill goes into that based on student and
District characteristics and then making
sure that every school district has
access to the resources they need to do
that through what what has historically
been and what would continue to be in in
this bill a partnership between local
property taxpayers and the state so
we're not telling local property
taxpayers that they're off the hook or
anything like that are not responsible
for education but making sure that that
that they don't have to
um be taxed at an unreasonable rate like
so many uh communities so many school
districts are having to tax
um uh out right now so the state makes
sure that every school district have has
access to the resources they need after
a reasonable local tax effort to uh to
to meet that that budget based on the
cost for the school district for the
students to have an uh to to perform at
a at a Statewide outcome and then that
ties directly in to the ad to the
accountability portion uh which uh which
starts on page 10 of a 20-page uh Bill
and um and this is really important
because it really does provide the
feedback mechanism for um for budgets
and then and then School operations and
then an accountability that's based on
what that budget
um how that budget was was designed so I
think it goes to a lot of the points
that are being made around here are you
paying teachers enough do you have
enough teachers do you have too many
teachers are you offering the right mix
of of um of of program or do you need a
different mix of program or do you need
different leadership in a district uh
and you know after uh after a number of
years and that's laid out in the
accountability section
um you can you can measure how the
students are doing are they are they are
they starting to approach a Statewide
outcome if not why not
and that's where that's where the
schools with the cooperation of the
department can put together a plan to
figure out what it is
um what it is they should be doing in
order for their students to um uh to be
to be getting to a Statewide outcome and
um and then the uh the mechanism for
calculating uh uh Statewide you know or
budgets for every school district based
on based on student student performance
that would also be Revisited at least
every I forget it's in the bill it's
every five years or every ten years I
think it's not not uh at least every
every 10 years and um
and
you know from a from an engineering
standpoint makes a lot of sense because
you're starting with um with with
funding based on a goal student outcomes
and then you're measuring that through
the accountability section when you
start out as a with a funding or a
budget mechanism based on how many desks
in a classroom one
principal for every 500 students
um uh stuff like that then how does the
accountability part work
um uh you know other other than just
measuring how much stuff that you've
you've purchased so so I I you know I
think from a from a um from uh from the
standpoint of does it make sense budget
based on outcomes fund to make sure that
districts have access to the resources
they need and then accountability based
on those those outcomes makes a lot of
sense we um we we can certainly
um and I think I think the bill needs
some work on on
you know how you define student outcomes
um you know Marjorie we've we've talked
about that maybe standardized tests
aren't the way to do it I mean right now
we look at Statewide assessment test
graduation rates and attendance rate but
there's a lot of other uh I mean that's
what the department collects now so
that's what we had to work with but um
but and maybe that's a place to start
and um and and maybe you know maybe it's
something that uh that the bill could
also include some uh some uh additional
data collection from the Department so
that we can improve on our ability to uh
to measure student outcomes down the
obviously we have a number of schools in
the state that are meeting
national standards they're meeting our
state standards and their outcomes are
very strong
then why do we have to change formula
for them
why aren't we addressing the schools
that are and let me read this one
section from this particular book which
was handed to us to me by Department of
Education it says if the current staff
is unable to raise student achievement
and the school district has failed to
correct the problem it is incumbent upon
the state to get the school back on the
right track
we endorse more local control and
flexibility but for that to be effective
the state must be prepared to act at the
local school district after a reasonable
period of time is clearly not getting
the job done now we have a number of
school districts that aren't getting the
job done my question is what have we
done through the state to get them up to
Snuff
that's the accountability that you know
do we have a hammer to do that do we
have the curriculum staff At Doe to do
that yes on that I think I was going to
follow up with what David was saying the
Dilemma that we've got is that right now
each School District gets 37.87 per
one side sits off
we can't Target that money though my
that's my point okay okay you're ahead
of me Rick that's the issue here is that
what we're trying to talk about here is
how do you begin to to identify where
there are problems
and provide the resources necessary to
fill those problems but here's the
Dilemma how do you avoid Claremont
here's the dilemma though
who helps those districts that are in
need
the current State Department of
Education doesn't have those resources
David just talked about getting more uh
more analysis and data collection they
can't do it now
so what we're suggesting here
is not just a funding formula
but looking at what the Department of
Education can do and hasn't been able to
do don't forget what's 85 percent of the
current staff of the department is
funded by federal funds I got all that
now but I'm worried about when I say
Claremont I'm not talking about the town
I'm talking about the court decision oh
okay the court decision would
Londonderry and all that
are we allowed to Target money like this
in the adequacy form in the base in the
differentiated component and David yeah
so let's let's address that and and uh
and if if representative Ames may want
to talk a little bit about this too um
uh this was an area that the school
funding commission took uh took a a very
significant look at and we had a lot of
testimony as you remember in this uh in
this area as well the um the the term
targeting
um goes back a long time and and
um uh for members of the committee it
means that uh that the that the state
would um would um be giving
um uh more amount more financial
resources to some districts than to want
them to than to other districts and um
uh and it and in some districts it may
be that those districts have access to
all the financial resources they need to
uh to run their run their school
district uh and to meet their um their
since Claremont and since Claremont New
Hampshire implemented as you as you said
Rick a basically a uniform uh
costing slash funding model that doesn't
matter doesn't matter if if if you're
the Newport School District or the
Hopkinton school district or the Hanover
School District or the Newcastle School
District you get the same costing slash
funding from the from the state in an
amount pretty much what what Mel was
said about four thousand forty two
hundred dollars something like that per
uh per student after you sort of wash it
all out and um and for uh for some
districts
well for every district and I think
there's a lot of arguments that say say
you know forty two hundred dollars
doesn't get you anywhere close to uh to
and to even even the the the uh per
pupil budget in in the district that
spends the least amount of money per
pupil the state which is Manchester
doesn't even get you halfway halfway
there pretty sure and um uh but for
other districts it um you know that have
that have access to tremendous resources
uh it uh it it does a lot for the
students in those districts and
and and but it it hasn't done anything
for Hanover I mean for um Clermont
hasn't done anything for the plaintiff
from for the in the in the Claremont
suit plaintiff towns so so I think the
the um you know our suggestion here is
that trying something different to close
those opportunity gaps across the state
so that a student who goes to Newport or
a student that goes to Claremont or
Berlin or Pittsfield or Manchester has
the same opportunities for success as a
student who goes to Hopkinton or or Beau
or Bedford and um
and you know there's a couple ways
there well there's a lot of different
ways of achieving that house bill 1690
um
um offers one way the school funding
commission report offers about a half a
dozen different ways uh of doing it this
1680 being one of them
um and um and you know and one way of
making making it compliant with with
with what uh with the chairs inter you
know with interpretation your
interpretation of it yes Rick is for the
state to pay the first and last dollar
and um you know of of
you know on average 18 19 20 000 per per
student
um that that's gonna put a significant
Challenge on on state revenues what 68
does is starts with what we're spending
right now
and uh and and works through organic
um you know uh you know as as economies
grow and um uh can uh can can phase in
over over a 10-year period doesn't put
any demands on new new tax sources it
does clean up I think a a constitutional
problem that we have with the state
property tax but but it doesn't put the
state in a position where it's spending
the first and last dollar for um for
school districts on what districts are
spending today and any and it it doesn't
level set budgets for school districts
it doesn't say all right you know it's
going to cost you reasonably you know
fifteen thousand dollars per student or
twelve thousand dollars per student or
twenty thousand dollars it doesn't do
that either it's actually looking at at
the the differences that in the
challenges that every school district
um has and you know I'm gonna overuse
you know you know something to sell time
but it costs more to educate a thousand
kids in Manchester than it does a
thousand kids in Bedford
why well I could easily say it just does
but because the Thousand kids in
Manchester present significantly
different challenges for the Manchester
School District than the Thousand kids
in Bedford do and and so that's what
1680 com contemplates so it comes up
with with a budget or a cost which is
separate from funding
currently costing and funding is the
same thing for every District
comes up with the with the budget for
costs
uh and then takes a look at a District's
ability to access resources to fund that
budget at a reasonable you know through
reasonable local tax effort and then the
state targets
the state funding to get the district
the rest of the way is Manchester going
to need more help yep Manchester is
going to need more help is Newcastle
going to need more help nope newcastle's
not going to need any more help
that's what that's what that does so it
works with this the state's existing
billion dollar you know plus or minus
um uh what the state's currently
spending uh on it so so it's a couple of
things it's fair for students it's fair
for taxpayers and I think it's fiscally
conservative you know in terms of um in
terms of what what sort of financial
obligations it places on the state of
New Hampshire for ensuring that every
student gets a um uh an opportunity for
an adequate education and yeah there's
other ways you can do it
um but um uh and I think you know I I'm
I'm I'm hopeful that someday we'll see
something like this and yep maybe it'll
get uh maybe it'll get challenged but
our current funding mechanism is getting
challenged because it hasn't made a
difference to students in Claremont or
any of the plaintiff districts since the
Claremont case when was um was
adjudicated and um and certainly we can
do better and that's what 1680
um and you know uh attempts to do and
I'll work with them I think you know
dick and Mel and I and Jay uh work with
anybody to um to to try to get there at
the final level whatever we put in place
has to be bipartisan it's got to be
durable it's got to be something that
stays around
um you know for the next 10 20
plus years so let's let's get back for a
second to what represent cordellia had
suggested let's look at the
accountability section within this
proposed legislation and that's a
concern I think I have as well that how
if it whatever we're going to do with a
funding formula how are we going to hold
the districts accountable with this
issue of local control
or what kind of measure are we going to
use to measure that they're performing
to this outcome that we're desirous of
achieving is it going to be the
Statewide assessment that we use
is it going to be
discipline in the schools is it going to
be you know the tenure of a an
individual the longevity in in there the
the leadership within the facility the
all the there's so many issues the the
turnover of the darn local school board
that impacts it tremendously
um the education levels within the
community there there are so many
factors outcomes how do you change some
of those so so accountability so I think
that's a great I I think there's a lot
of contributing a lot of factors that
contribute to student outcomes but what
you can measure is student outcomes I
mean this is this is
this is you know I'd call it a quality
control Loop and and you know at the at
the at the end of the day what matters
most is our student outcomes and and
um you know if a district is getting
strong student outcomes by um
uh you know what what
I mean uh uh uh the Hamilton School
District may have a completely different
um I don't know what we want to call it
I'm not an expert in this area faculty
profile then the Concord School District
or the bow School District but they
don't have to be exactly the same as
long as they're as long as the the
accountability part through student
outcomes is being met can we Define that
well currently in the bill it's defied
it's defined I'm on page 10 down at line
34.
um uh and it's uh and it's
in in this case that is included but not
limited to performance on Statewide
assessment tests graduation rates and
attendance rates
and uh but but I I think you could have
dip you could have different
um
um ways of measuring outcomes measuring
student outcomes based on student
performance uh doesn't have to be those
I I this was the data that we had so
that we could evaluate it during the
school funding commission work and um
um but it could be it could be others
um as well and uh but but what's what's
important about these three is that
we've got we've got the we've got these
data for every district for the last
decade and we're able to uh to look at
um how students performed uh in each
district based on their their uh their
based on those District budgets and
we're able to to to to to look at the
different characteristics in each
district and then determine a way of of
predicting what a uh what a school
district's budget would be to educate
its students their students to a
Statewide outcome
I think rep Sammy Porter than Turner
Tanner and anybody over here represent I
I'm sure there's no way to really do
this but one
um way of measuring and effectiveness of
an education is the future of the child
or the or the student
um and we never talk about
what happened you know looking at the
outcomes
five years down the road from high
school graduation where are our
graduates what are they doing you know
what kind of Life are they living are
they contributing members of society or
have they landed up on the streets
um that's something that we really need
to look at
and and evaluate but yet we don't have a
method in here at all I mean maybe this
isn't the aspect of it but it is an
important thing are our students going
out into the world and being civically
engaged economically profit economically
surviving and having you know going on
and being part of our general community
and our in our democracy those are the
things we need to be looking at but
we're always talking about standardized
tests and graduation
um which doesn't give us a clue about
even some of these these schools where
we're talking about low performance and
I'm sure that if you looked at their
graduate level graduation you know their
students after graduation find they're
in the military they're out in the
workforce they married their families
they're working at the in their jobs
they're happy productive members of
society isn't that
what we're after
and to get back representative lad to
the to the reading that you did from
some book that you said
um talking about you had gotten from the
Department of Education it sounded to me
very much like what was the basis for
the No Child Left Behind Act the schools
aren't doing their job we've got to
punish them
and um it's time for the state to step
in and and do something well that's
exactly what the Federal Government
tried to do with No Child Left Behind
grading schools you're going to close
schools down they're going to fire all
the teachers and hire hire new ones
because obviously they weren't doing
what they were supposed to be doing and
that misses the point of why the
performance is low and we keep skirting
around it because we don't want to
identify what the real issue is and the
real issue in my opinion is economics
and and we have to make sure that all
kids have an a fair chance from they're
all starting at the same starting line
they're not all starting at the same
starting line you know what the kids
that have European vacations when
they're five years old are in a very
different place than the kids who are at
home with their mother or their
grandmother watching television until
they go to school so until we can
address that issue I don't think it's
fair for the state to say we're going to
go in and punish these schools you know
if a den just if someone goes to the
dentist and the dentist says you know
brush your teeth you're going to get
cavities and they go home and they don't
brush their teeth and they get cavities
is that the dentist's fault or is it the
fault of something else
thank you I just had to get that off my
I'm not going to be here much longer Mr
Mr chair and I really have to get some
of these things off in my chest and this
is one of them you know I'm sick and
tired of being blaming blaming blaming
all the time on the school tour have
people in there working their hearts out
to do what's best for the kids and if
they're not the kids are not achieving
to what some artificial level that we
say they should be achieving to those
teachers and those schools are made to
feel like they're not very good there's
something wrong with them nobody wants
to be part of them and I I take
exception to that because there I have
never seen a teacher who didn't care
you're welcome
representative Tanner
thank you
um I guess two things one would be that
I
would like to see something in
accountability that actually measures
growth over time that people don't get
you know schools vary so much from year
to year
um
what students they have what teachers
they have what
um things that may happen in the local
community that makes quite a difference
on perhaps how they do on testing and
that sort of thing so I think something
has to like Dave said things have to be
over a long period of time I think the
accountability needs to be taken over a
long period well not as long maybe as 10
years but a couple of years in a row or
five years in a row my other thought is
that we have some schools in New
Hampshire who have made tremendous
turnarounds Parker Varney is one of them
that I remember going to a a conference
um and the
as as Mel said it started with
leadership
it also started with collaboration with
the Department of Education
but that was the school that turned it
around Pittsfield for a while made a
turnaround but then then lost it because
they couldn't sustain it I think it
would be important as part of this whole
thing to look at schools that have made
a turnaround and what made the
difference and I'm I'm guessing that
there are a few
things that we're missing totally
um I worked in a school district where
we had so many people stay for so long
they had to offer us a bonus to leave
okay
um so and why why did people stay so
long and why did the school do really
well well one of the things was that the
The Faculty the the teachers were
intimately involved in all the decisions
of the school we felt as though we were
were part of it we weren't it wasn't top
down management
um we had when we first started the
school we had a Department of Education
under
um
uh I forget his first name uh Marsden
Who's Who Came Charlie Marston who came
you know organized a group that came to
our school uh talked to us about
curriculum uh spotted things in the
community that um we needed to do in
order to get the community behind it
because we were one of the first open
schools in the state of New Hampshire
and
um it was a radical change in how
education was being
um given and and what the school climate
was going to be like and the curriculum
itself so
um you know it was it was creative we
could we could actually do things as
teachers we were able to take the
standards that were given us and and be
creative in what we did and work to our
strengths uh teach what people were
strong at uh English teachers were
allowed to teach Shakespeare if that was
their strong point we've set so many
regulations from the state down on what
happens in the classroom and what
happens in the schools people are
handcuffed and it's and it's you know
it's it's really made it tough
um to teach I mean that's that's why
you're getting teachers leaving that's
one of the big reasons you're getting
teachers leaving I I can't tell you how
many times I've talked to teachers I
know I've said it myself I just want
politics out of my classroom
and those people at the state level have
no idea what's going on down in the
school level I I said that and heard it
and still hear it over and over again so
I think when we're talking about
outcomes and we're talking about schools
and I know we're at a 30 000 foot level
but we also have to look at the at the
Five Mile level or the one mile level or
maybe the 50 Feet level of being in that
classroom and and helping our teachers
and and feeling as though education is
being supported
um in order for that to filter down to
student outcomes because the magic
happens between the teacher and the
student that's where the magic happens
representative cordello you had your
hand up yeah thank you
um first uh I don't know that the state
is punishing
um any schools
um that are not performing
um going back to Essa
um and the state plan for Essa
um and even before there are the lower
performing schools I think it's five and
ten percent of the lowest performing
schools were referred to as uh
um CSI comprehensive support
um I can't remember the exact uh acronym
but CSI and TSI schools and they did get
um according to the state plan
additional supports in terms of
assistance and
Improvement plans and so forth and
working with the Department to the
extent that that Improvement plan
um is in place today and and how much
the level of those supports might have
to go back and look at the original plan
so there are supports for those lower
performing schools
and I think that's the we can't say that
the state is punishing low performing
schools I don't think that that is the
case at all
whether we're going to go over this year
a little bit representative Nelson you
thank you Mr chairman of Life what a
wonderful conversation and I wish I was
going to rain again just to be part of
all this
um I see a little I agree with everybody
and what they say that's extremely
important but I just jotted that a few
things
I always ask as a person both students
what they who is their best teacher in
high school when they're out and who was
their least favorite their worst teacher
it's interesting to gather that
information
the other one is the very common is the
teacher teaches what they like
they make I've heard many times teachers
teach the Civil War and you're supposed
to do a whole bunch of stuff and they
spend three quarters of the Year
teaching the Civil War how you get
involved and get that corrected that the
teacher teaches the curriculum from one
end to the other rather than just what
they like oh two more things
um money doesn't save everything or
solve everything
it doesn't for any of us and it's great
to have money but it doesn't
and exit interviews would be one as I
mentioned before
um let's see two other things
teachers don't always leave because of
money it's a big factor I would agree a
good percentage do many of them leave
because they're not happy with the
school
the administration
you know they're just things aren't
going right and they're just giving up
now throughout the time bomb on this
whole thing or model explosion I think
I've been a union member my entire
career two different unions and I
support the unions sometimes they
support teachers that aren't so good
how do we resolve that without getting
the politics out or being anti-union to
move out the teachers that are not
helping that's all I have to say
ditto representative Tanner said on
motivating on teacher and student is
where the magic happens
and the regulations and the rules and
all of this stuff gets in the way of the
teacher I know when I did my student
teaching I was so disgusted because I
was doing math math you have to have all
the pieces to move on to the next pieces
and I was given a and I loved my
students in my classes
who were missing a lot of pieces and I
spent a lot of time picking up those
pieces but I had to be at the same place
the same day as everybody else but my
students weren't the same as everybody
else and I worked my butt off to try to
get my students there and I can remember
begging can I have one more week
just one more week my kids are almost
there
but no I couldn't I had to be at this
place and I had to go on even though my
kids weren't there yet and I talked to
other early you know Math teachers and
they were making the same complaints and
they were like and and I just felt
and we kind of agreed that the system
was set up for students and teachers to
fail
that's what it felt like
and
that's something we need to be looking
at it doesn't have to do with funding it
has to do with how are we doing the
schools are we letting teachers teach
are we trying to treat every student
every kid every whatever exactly the
same and March them along in this you
must be here you must be here you must
be here without taking any account of
who the kids are what their background
is what they know just like Rhett Porter
was saying we get kids are very very
different and they come from different
backgrounds and they have different
strengths and weaknesses and that how do
we address that
I was sitting over here and I whispered
to my colleagues sitting here the one
word I had not heard in this entire
discussion
and it was qualitative
no one mentioned changing the quality of
what we're doing we talked about how
many people we needed what kind of
support numbers all that sort of thing
but if you absent qualitative
achievement from a discussion of Finance
I can guarantee you you will not get
what you want in outcome it's just not
possible
we need to address that elephant in the
room as well
we may not be preparing teachers
to do what we want them to do
and we need to involve them in this
discussion too
so I would say that this discussion
needs to include the teacher preparation
institutions as well
is all we're talking about here because
if we don't educate the communities for
what to hire for
and then they in turn will by their
hiring practices change the nature of
what's going on in the teacher
preparation process
will never have the outcomes we're
looking for
it has to be a component
just tell you one little factoid that
when you enlist in the Marine Corps you
finish High School
that's fine you wave your high school
diploma they sign you up
the first thing they do is give you an
examination
and you get a score I've forgotten what
the test is called but I'll find out
again and pass it on to you
and that score determines what schools
you get to go to what kind of training
you have every single thing they do in
training a marine has an educational
theory substantiating it
down to the order of doing push-ups and
pull-ups and all the physical stuff and
when you do it
and how it comes out and how then you
apply those skills that's all sequenced
I don't think we do that much in our
public schools now not everybody is a
concrete sequential learner or whatever
it's true we like all get along together
but I think we need to be teaching
smarter
and I think we're not letting or
enabling that to happen as we keep
talking about with the blind teachers
and not requiring those others who
aren't teaching that well the maybe this
is not the feel for you
enough said I think this group's
abstract random
and uh
represent Luna
so so thanks Rick all right just uh just
a follow-up question oh wait wait what
you're talking about so I want to take I
want to take a couple of school
districts
um Hopkinton where I live
it's about
um 15 minutes from here and
um and I think our average student in
Hopkins I'm not looking at it right now
but it you know somehow I I think the
average student at Hopkinton performs at
about the 84th 85th percentile State
Line you go up the road a half hour from
Hopkinton to Newport and the average
student in Newport performs
um at about the fourth percentile
Statewide
I'm trying to understand how
and and and honestly I think I think all
mo I think a lot of our discussion has
been about quality because when we're
talking about student outcomes that's a
quality assessment of of of how students
are performing we can disagree on you
know you know the the specific
assessments but it is a quality
assessment
but but how do you explain uh based on
what you just said
um the uh the the difference in in in in
in in
outcomes from Hopkinton and then going a
half hour up the road and and half hours
the reason I'm putting that out there is
it's not three hours up the road it's
not five hours up the road it's a half
hour up the road
um
um are they
are they hiring the wrong teachers not
enough teachers too many teachers
teachers that aren't
I I mean teaching that are teaching
something different what what what are
you what do you attribute based on what
you what you just said to that such a
stark difference between student
outcomes in districts that are only a
yes
in the co-mingle ballots is it required
to call co-mingle ballots where multiple
towns send somebody to school
mingle Bells where they will count put
all the towns into together and then
they count the ballots without knowing
how each Town voted when I was in
Vermont and we're going back a long time
ago they used to co-mingle them so we
never knew what our local school or town
how they felt about the school because
the number would be 1 000 or whatever
and we had a small school we never knew
how they felt
as a town for their elementary school
but I don't know what they do here in
New Hampshire
no no they don't co-mingle
okay
yes
um I I love the discussion that we're
having today and I feel like it's
probably the most productive discussion
I've sat in on over the past two years
so I just want to start by saying it
makes me really happy
um
I agree with something that just about
everybody here has said and I keep going
back to the money where we talk about we
talked about this before putting more
money into the schools I do feel like
it's it's deeper and I don't know how to
fix it but I don't know if it's
something you need to look at maybe more
of the before or the after school
programs we're saying that it's
something that has to do with the home
life versus what's happening during the
school day I'm wondering if we can take
a deeper dive into the social economic
aspects of things and try to figure out
how to help these kiddos that way I
don't know if that's too big for us here
but but this is what's been weighing on
me for for quite a while
um and then the other question that I
have for you
we're talking about
um kind of the bandwidth or how much
money these schools have right to
support their students we talk about
let's say a Hopkinton versus a Newport
right the state is giving a certain
amount and we're saying what these
communities can or cannot afford on
their own but what determines that it my
my perception has been it's um the
tolerance of the community for lack of a
better word right their threshold or
their tolerance because the money that's
being spent on these budgets is being
put forth by the administrators or the
school board but the final amount is
being determined at delivery Obsession
and or on Election Day is that a fair
assessment of what the towns across the
state can afford or is it what those
voters are choosing to put toward
education I don't know the answer to
that it's just a thought I've had while
we were discussing this thank you
boy that's got a lot of questions in it
and what you're asking us I I'll I'll
try to address a situation which
happened in this state
years ago White Mountain Community
College had an academic center in my
community
and it got to the point where White
Mountain could no longer afford to
Supply staff for that academic center
which was part of White Mountain
Community College
simply because there was not an enough
students participating in the program
within the community
Ray Burton and I worked like the devil
to try to keep that Center there
and worked with the superintendent of
schools and he was very interested but
when I got beyond that level in the
schools
the principal did not engage
and the community as a result who worked
with that principal did not engage and
for a long time people are thinking well
it's how this community aspires to
education the aspiration of what my
child's going to be when they leave
school they said well they're they're
not going to need college they're going
to go off and work in the woods or
they're going to become diesel mechanics
over queer tech center or they're gonna
that type of skill orientation which now
I wish a lot more would do because you
could probably get more money in those
skills than you can and some of the
things coming out of college with but at
any rate we lost our Academic Center
and I equate that loss not necessarily
to what we tried as a legislature we
tried like the devil we worked with um
with the the chair of the State Board of
Education uh we worked with the
community college system we worked with
the trustees and Ray Burton was the
person back in those days and he
couldn't make any Headway either
it was I think a result of leadership in
that particular facility that they
didn't take advantage of the academic
program that was there there is a lot of
things that the the organization the
trans and she had staff and all there we
just didn't have support locally in the
schools and so the quality of your staff
and the quality of the staff in the in
the way that staff works with the
community is very important but I also
say to all of us here that there is a
need for this data that and
decision-making is all oftentimes driven
by data that's a reality of our society
anytime we go to the legislature we're
going to ask for more money for
something I'm going to say show me show
me your your sound data that justify
that increase or wherever you're going
and when we I I worked the other day
with the folks over in the data
processing of doe with Caitlin Davis and
and and Nate Nate green who is in charge
of research and the assessment
Improvement performance program
and I my question initially to them was
what are we doing we have we know that
many of students coming back to school
are five months if not more behind the
mathematics same thing basically in
Reading as well as a result of this
pandemic
mathematics is not necessarily just
related to the pandemic we've always
been kind of slippery in that area over
the years here there's been a waterfall
effect when the kids hit the middle
school and when they get to the high
school they were not performing the way
they should and that's why we had
remediation at the community college
level 60 percent of the kids had to have
remediation which 50 never got an
associate's degree that's a problem
so I asked what are we doing with these
assessment results at the department we
get the scores posted to us they're on
the web immediately upon taking that
test but are you doing the Deep dive
some districts are just throwing out
their whole math program starting over
with scratch or can you tell me what
specific areas within mathematics
instruction and curriculum were weak in
well we don't we don't do an analysis of
that test that deep down and we want to
but we don't have the Personnel to do
that I heard the analysis uh spoken to
earlier that there is a bill in there
now to provide the department the staff
to to do that deep dive and
Analysis of our math results maybe it's
enumeration maybe it's Sumerian geometry
maybe it's this or that we don't know
and the schools don't have the staff to
do this either they're they they take
those results they use them they share
with parents and they they they look at
them and oftentimes they make that quick
decision well we got to do something
about this curriculum we're going to
rewrite the whole darn thing maybe
that's not necessary so
um I I think part of the issue is we've
looked at the quality of you know the
staff there in in the schools but also I
look at the the staff we have at
department of education do we have the
support there from doe in those
curriculum areas we once had those
curriculum coordinators and staff for do
we have the data analysis going over
there which is looking at the research
and the the content that we're using to
are we speaking to how to really improve
are we just you know doing you know more
of the same old same old
um I believe we're not doing an analysis
the way we should and that's why I will
support an analysis position over there
too do that deep dive with school
districts and share that so when I'm
developing Chris curriculum at the which
is my responsibility at the local level
I'm doing a revision of curriculum
that's in line with what the state
standards are
and so we've had this I think a golf
between doe and and and what's happening
in the schools
and I don't think it's intentional I
think it's lack of Staffing eighty
percent of the staff over there are
federally funded employees
looking at title one looking at this
looking at that but they're not doing
what we need to have done and so we're
not funding that right
either so we look at trying to change
what we're doing in in in their funding
of adequacy we need to look
farther afield to find out how we're
going to support the schools and I don't
think we're doing an adequate job as a
state because local control you have
instruction you have curriculum so we're
out of that game
representative
speaking of uh assessment I've been
thinking about this a bunch and I think
you really have to follow individual
students and how they're doing and
whether they're improving
in their areas and not take an average
of a class you know anybody who's been
in a school knows that different classes
have different cultures different
abilities that you know you can you can
have one class that that are very
studious in the next class that like to
goof around and it seems you know and
you see that right
so comparing that way is not going to
work but we have the ability every kid
takes these tests we have the results
I think we need to be tracking it need
to be
um
looking to see is each student improving
is that student improving and we have
the ability to do that now with this
position I think it's coming in I think
some schools are doing this I think
they're tracking the core heart if
you're a third grader in 2006 seven year
fourth grader fifth grade or sixth
grader they're following a cohort but
they're also looking at individual
students yeah and that's being done
that's the best practice but when I
spoke with Nate green the other day over
at Doe
they are just starting to do this and we
will have a legislative oversight
committee on September 27th when they're
going to come in and present that
information to us and they're going to
do it by cohort by grade levels kids
following that seeing where exactly
things are going Askew but that's that's
beyond where you're you're talking about
the individual I'm talking now about
State and hopefully individual school
districts and we don't have that data
yet but we have the state we'll be
looking at those courts those seats will
be handed out then with the recent
yes president Woodcock thank you um you
know I I have several comments about I
will try to put them back down I want to
go back to what uh Tana said uh the
quality of instruction uh is the
difference in that classroom when you
shut that door and all the factors of
going to the teacher training teacher
professional development pay attrition
all those things and the other one we
haven't mentioned is a student we're the
students out developmentally uh where
are they and the better instructing
instruction you have those teachers can
identify within that classroom setting
where each other needs to work but they
have to have the toolbox to bring each
chunker along the answer is in the
classroom initially so I think that's
that's the key we've we've forgotten
about because that helps terrifically
the other part is just reflecting on uh
was talking about the scores and we do
test item analysis we do we can identify
right down to what particular
fundamental masculine and where they
lost it where they missed it they're
looking at class what's and what teacher
at indoor did do it
um so that that can be done but I would
agree that the doe has not been on the
ball uh because they spent too much down
time or the last four or five years you
talk about a principal of school or
administrative School District with the
same thing with the commissioner of
Education he's out there create a whole
lot more programs just to think we took
all the time and invested our money and
put public education first
so it goes right across the board I mean
we as a state a commission a
commissioner and doe has not invested
all their funds into looking at how to
make these things better uh along the
way we'll talk about schools and
teachers administrators so it's not it's
not just uh that point but clearly the
quality instruction in the classroom is
the fundamental priest that makes uh
schools succeed and makes kids succeed
now just to follow up on that you know
when I came in here in the house I
wanted to see these so-called curriculum
Frameworks
which are guidelines which don't exist
going they were gone way back when
they've been gone for we we of course we
no longer have in statute because they
weren't doing them but if I wanted to
find out what the fiscal education
curriculum was for this state I'd have
to go back to what 2004 and and and so
yeah we have standards which are in
ed306 but that's that's not what we need
that's not that's not this
commissioner's fault no that's that's
the but that's illusion that's been
going on in the Department of Education
in this state I was very surprised when
I moved to this state
and I went to the department to try to
get all this curriculum information
my school district where I was before I
had more staff than this doe has
and and we had that we all our
curriculum CRT curriculum reference
tests for each area we wrote those
ourselves
so you know I think that if we want to
see Improvement we're going to have to
have Improvement Beyond just this
funding formula which I concur we need
to change this around we need more
accountability within it and we probably
need to I don't know if we need to throw
if twenty thousand dollars per student
is a lot of money per student now
granted it's not State money it's
property tax money as well local money
but we need to reorient I think where
the dollars might be used more
effectively it's not always more money
it's how effective we're using our
current money
and that is a question that we need to
address when we're looking at this
costing formula how effective is the
current Formula being used that money
and I we've tried to address that would
swap a little bit but I think that's a
component that this group right here we
got to discuss that before we do
anything this year I agree with that as
well representative lab but all
districts don't have that pot of money
to work with
because they don't have that money
that's what this program is 1680 at
least not to develop so there is a part
of mind that everybody has an equal shot
you're absolutely correct if we don't
have the money to work with it doesn't
matter because you can't get what you
need done
it's pretty tough when you have 196
districts so how many have we ever had
in this state you know for everybody to
be replicating what everybody else is
doing there's that's not effective use
of the coin representative and then
representative uh cordelli thanks very
much Rick
um uh just just uh um I just wanted to
talk to a couple of points that that
were just made by you and actually and
represent Litchfield as well but um but
one of the things that um that that 1680
does uh based on the um the school
funding commission work is and this is a
really important part when when looking
at what it cost what it would cost a
district to educated students to a
Statewide outcome it um it looks at um
it first of all it gets away
inefficiencies because that's one of the
things about looking at all state all
School District budgets over over a
decade in student outcomes they were
able to identify inefficiencies in in
school budgets and then and then look at
a way to to develop School budgets based
on achieving
um those those outcomes so so you could
look at at for instance
um and I'll pick the two examples that
that Melissa and I used uh Newport and
Hopkinton you could look at the number
of students that that live in low-income
households number that are special
education the different factors that we
that we do look at the end the student
outcomes in there and then look at how
those budgets were built and what they
were you know what their spending
categories were and and essentially be
able to Baseline them
so that now if I know that a school
district has a you know a certain you
know a higher or a lower number of
special education students or higher or
lower number of students that live in
that come from low income uh backgrounds
how much it would cost for the for those
districts to um to uh to deliver an
adequate education based on you know
students achieving a Statewide average
so so so to your to your point Rick
um the a large part of this work was to
identify the inefficiencies but more
importantly identify the efficiencies
that lead to student outcomes and um and
how that reflects across districts with
different student characteristics
um the um the other uh Point um that I
think representative Litchfield was was
talking about and this is and
representative Woodcock uh mentioned it
uh as well
um at what point do you look at a
District's access to resources and say
that's all we're going to spend I don't
want to spend a dime more fourth
percentile is good enough for us versus
I'm just tapped out there's not a dime
more that I can spend to to on our
school district and we still can't raise
you know the money for an adequate
budget so that I can get an adequate uh
student outcome and um when you take a
look at Hopkinton yep we're near the top
in the state in terms of how much we're
spending
um on our on our tax rate
um and um you know we got some unique
things in our community I think it it it
it definitely has a has a diverse
socioeconomic mix but uh and this is a
stressful time and it's been 12 years in
front of taxpayers Janet Bennett all
those meetings and uh and it's and it's
you know pretty stressful because you've
got a lot of people with with
substantial means that that you know
nobody he likes paying property taxes
but you know we want we want to have
great schools so so we raise the we
raise the money and I think you know we
passed more budgets than than we lose in
um in Hopkinton but then you go half
half hour up the road to uh to Newport
guess what they're paying nearly the
same tax rate as what we're paying in
Hopkinton and uh and they can't even
fund
on a per on a per student basis you know
uh 70 of the budget that we're that
we're funding in Hopkinton they're
topped out
they're just tapped out and and I think
that's that's really what what you know
what we're saying here
um and I think it goes It goes to what
Steve was saying you know in terms of
where you know how does how can the
state
use its precious limited resources
um to make sure that that that students
aren't paying the price when taxpayers
get tapped out and um uh and finally
that's what they're doing and actually
we wouldn't be breaking new ground in
this area because Massachusetts does it
uh they've been on the road to their
Massachusetts Chapter 70 plan
um which um which recognizes it that
that you know what the um the the the
taxpayers in in in Lawrence shouldn't be
working
six times harder than the taxpayers in
in Wellesley and getting you know poor
student outcomes because they they can't
even put to get fund the budget that
they should that they that they need uh
to be competitive in a in a you know in
a global market global economy and um
and so uh so you know so big points and
and I and I think Melissa was right on
when asking that question you know how
do we know how do we know well you can
take a look at the student outcomes and
you can take a look at the tax rates in
a lot of these communities they're
trying super hard
they just can't get them
and we're trying super hard in Hopkinton
too but we do get there
um but um but you know that's we
obviously we have we have a very
socio-economically diverse demographic
across our state as well and um and and
you know if the state is going to take
its obligation
to uh assuring that every student has an
opportunity to an adequate education uh
then um then and take that seriously and
I do believe the state takes it
seriously you just take a look at what
they're spending right now you know
billion dollars a year that's you know
as far as general fund slash education
trust fund I mean that's the biggest
pile of of that's the biggest expense
our state has and certainly when you
take a look at all in with the local
property taxpayers
which is about double that it's about
another two billion dollars all in where
three billion dollar on public schools
it's a it's an it's an enormous price
tag we get a lot
for the state's Collective
three billion dollars
top five
um you know student outcomes nationally
but not every District's getting that
and um and and that's why you know I I
think 1680 looks to looks to provide a
little bit of fairness actually a lot of
fairness into uh making sure that that
that the kids up in Newport
um you know get a fair Shake too I mean
I've spent I've spent a dozen years on
the board making sure that that the kids
in Hopkinton get a fair shake and as a
taxpayer a lifetime taxpayer in
Hopkinton making sure that our kids get
up get a fair Shake but uh but Newport
needs some help too Pittsfield needs
some help too so many other places
Jefferson cordelli yeah thank you I just
have to go back to some prior comments
and disagree and um and that I think
that the commissioner and the department
have done a fantastic job in programming
to help students
um you have YES scholarship programs you
have summer scholarship programs for
students you have reading training for
teachers and adults free tutoring
available I think that
they've done a marvelous job
um sometimes maybe getting the word out
to parents and others about
um availability of these programs is an
issue that we could do better at but I
think that they've done a great job in
trying to help students and recover the
learning loss from the pandemic
representative Tanner and then
representative Lexus I think we have to
realize too that it's a vicious cycle
um public schools are kind of a keystone
of a community and I live in Sunapee and
10 minutes down the road is Newport
and Sunapee is rated even higher than
Hoppington I think and we spend more
money and I my taxes are a lot lower
than Newports okay
um
but Newport uh because it's so close and
because it is a town I represent until
December
um it's a vicious cycle for them okay
the schools aren't doing well they can't
afford the what's happening there
the people they hire at the
administrative level or at the business
administrator you talk about how many
different superintendents Claremont had
I can't tell you how many business
administrators different ones they've
had at Newport the new ones come in
don't know the system they don't know
how to get grants they don't know how to
effectively use the money
um so the school is you know it's it's a
vicious cycle within the school the
teachers leave because they aren't
getting paid this the townspeople are
upset with the school so they're
constantly on their backs it's you know
to go to a school board meeting is is a
difficult thing because people are
yelling at each other versus some other
school districts care Sarge for example
where people are very calm and very
supportive of the school but it also
affects the community
the community can't get businesses there
um they have one major business rugers
and if that goes boy they're going to be
some hurting so they have to be very
careful how they deal with rugers
um the school district
that the kids coming out of the school
district there's been some that have
gone on to really great colleges Harvard
Dartmouth
um you know done well at UNH that sort
of thing but a number of them have gone
on to those colleges and they they can't
take it because they're they're coming
from that kind of community and they
don't have the the support at home they
don't have the support with the
community and they have the skills but
they just can't they can't deal with uh
what's before them and oftentimes they
drop out of college and they come back
and then they have student loans so
what we're doing is so important not
only for the kids of New Hampshire and
the students of New Hampshire but it's
important to all the communities in New
Hampshire particularly the ones like
Berlin Newport Manchester because it's
making a difference in their economic
ability it's making a difference in
their daily lives it's making a
difference in what opportunities the
kids have have there and how that
Community thrives throughout
and we're not just we're not just
educating for soldiers to make everybody
you know into a little soldier that that
has the same basis we're not educating
kids necessarily to be workers we're
educating them as Marjorie said
for the for a human being for a
productive member of society and that
might mean an artist or it might mean a
musician or it might mean an engineer or
it might mean somebody going into the
Marines okay but it means everybody it
can't be just the qualitative things
can't be so tight that we're losing
sight of the whole child and
comprehensive school education
thanks Rick let me get back to the 30
000 foot here for a second
then there is a threshold question here
that school funding needs to address
and that is a thing that I've said all
along and that is
are we going to are we concerned about
our kids
think about that
the issue of our kids
looks at all kids around all students I
hate that term kids all students across
the state
and if you're worried about developing a
a Workforce
we can't just be worried about the
students in Hopkinton
more isolated students in Bedford or in
Newport we need to begin to look at what
is the opportunity for all of our kids
because if I'm going to come in if I'm a
business person I want to start a
business
I I'm not looking at just one Community
because I'm going to be gathering
students and workers from a variety of
different communities
and so I think one of the one of the
things that we did on the commission
was really looked at the concept of our
students across the state
and where are those students that need
help
as David was saying you know there are
communities that are Tapped Out
and what is our what's our
responsibility of the state
to look at those communities and to
provide some resources there that they
may not be able to provide for
themselves just because their tax base
is much lower than others across the
state
so for me the question is is how do we
take the resources that we currently
have in our state and that's what the
commission looked at
the commission looked at what are the
what's the the billions of dollars that
were currently providing for
how do we allocate those in a different
way
that can help those students
and look at the issue of our kids
in a generic way across the state rather
than just looking at what my child is
getting in a particular community
I know that's a tough question to deal
with because we all want the best for
our child
but there's a greater hole out here
that this is trying that this that this
bill is trying to address and I know
it's it's a very difficult concept
because it's so intricate it's had so
many parts here but we I would hope that
this committee
based upon the conversations that we
have had or and will have
will say you know this is an issue folks
we need to look at this
in a systemic kind of a way
and create a a system that's fair
thank you very much Mel
I'll go go ahead
I wanted to go back to
um
what Rhett Porter had said about the
number one thing which determines
outcome is the education level of the
parents
and I saw that in Nashua
um because Nash was one school district
right and they have the same people the
same school board the same everything
and yet the different schools have
different outcomes and you look at it
it's not because one school has access
to more money than another school has
because it's all one District
but it's drawing the schools are
neighborhoods schools and they're
drawing from different education levels
of the parents and it makes a huge
difference so I think before we say oh
well let's just give these guys more
money
let's look at what is it that makes the
difference
in those kids in how they do based on
the education level of their parents and
how what are we going to do in the
school that's going to make up for
whatever it is
that it you know that isn't happening or
is happening or whatever I think I think
before we start putting
divvying up money we need to figure out
what is it for how can we make a
difference what is the difference
between what's going on with the kids
who have a better education better
educated parents and those that don't
because you see it in Nashua and that
has nothing to do with how much money a
community can have or any of that
because it's all the same Community it's
all the same school district
types of neighborhoods with different
types of Education of the parents and so
I hate to just throw money at something
and say well give it more money and and
it'll magically happen I think we need
to be looking at underlying issues what
thank you um we're getting close to
lunch here and um
I had planned on having some you know a
presentation from doe today on special
education this afternoon but she was not
available
uh but what I'd like to do is that we've
had a good discussion on our situation
we have in terms of the foundation
formula for the state of adequacy and
funding of it and I think we all have in
our own minds of of where we'd like to
be
and but the question is how are we going
to get there I think what we need to do
is that we need to each of us take 1680
between now and the time we meet again
look it over look down at that and say
does this have some of the elements
within it that are going to get us to
that Target we want to get to in terms
of funding education in our state
at the end of uh this whole discussion
we answer a subcommittee have the
responsibility of making a
recommendation either up or down or up
up with recommendations down for some
reason whatever to the full education
committee and then that of course report
goes into the calendar for the whole uh
Community to our legislature to have so
I'd like to between now and the time we
meet again look at 1680
renew yourself with what's in here
then come back and say here's some of
the real components of that that I like
here's some areas that maybe that you
may be looked at and and some healthy
discussion on I don't want I I don't
want to come in here and not spin our
Wheels but discuss uh all the reasons
why we had this before us we know those
reasons we know them that there's you
know there are the communities that are
like the berlins of the world and the
new parts of the world and then we do
know that there's the lebanons of the
world and the the communities which have
the wherewithal and and actually can
show us
what they're doing is great their their
scores reflect that and the kids are
going on to the world of work and and
with the skills that they need my
community may not need to have students
going off with all those type of skills
they may need some other type of skills
which are or you know taught through a
different way but it's all part of our
world there is different than the world
down in Rochester
so or or Portsmouth
so so yes
a question our is our our task here I
believe
is to make one of two recommendations
right one is no we don't recommend any
further action or or further legislation
or yes we need further legislation are
those are the two options we with that
latter option you've always you've
mentioned yes we need further
legislation but we've also attached to
many of the issues we've discussed
recommendations to improve upon or to
change to get that going forward
um I think that's very important
component
so that's what we've got to really start
honing in on is if we can and we should
everybody should be taking a healthy
look at this this bill
and and looking over and saying because
I can look at that bill too and there
are a lot of areas I like there were
some areas which I had questioned you
know I don't know how to measure the
attitude of the teacher in the classroom
I don't know whether they're you know
it's the quality teacher or not or or
you know other than through the local
principle of doing the observations
saying you don't meet our what we have
for our goals in this school or the
standards of the state and or how do you
measure the the the parent uh and
involvement in in working the you know
we know that we have a lot of issues
that other health impaired category
within the IEPs is skyrocketing on us
and that's the result of the pandemic
and and some of the parenting skills
that have gone on and the the kids not
being in schools
um so that there are a lot of issues
that I that a test is not necessarily
going to be the answer to assess that
but but in order to attain the goal I
have of really helping the districts
which need the help
what are their specific needs and will
additional dollars do that I want to
really delve into that a little bit
myself and I think we need to and would
you please grab a copy of that if you
don't have one that we commission
two boxes and I would recommend
it's a big doc yeah but there is an
executive summary
that does a really good job about my uh
what the executive summary of the
recommendation yeah
now don't let the dollar figure of
anything scare you away let's let's look
at you know the policy decisions within
that and the elements uh I I know that
we will be looking at dollars uh but in
for this committee we want to look does
this will this get to where we need to
get
Mr chair
um could you tell us about the book that
you have over there the the name of it
and the author sure
it's called schoolhouses courthouses and
state houses
and
believe it or not when I talked with
Bill ardinger just last Friday
said this book basically says we're
looking for performance outcomes we're
looking exactly what the bill is trying
to do as well it it doesn't get down in
all the the key elements that are within
the bill but it does say outputs
performance is what we want to be
looking at so there's a lot of parallels
in this book here and it's a it's a yes
it came out a few years ago it's older
but
there's a lot of good research there
then we don't want to throw it out
so
um I I I would encourage if you can get
a hold of something like this look it
over uh
it's kind of boring to read all the
parts within it but it has some his
chapters which are kind of meaty you may
have liked that uh uh
so okay so yes
March
I was wondering if there's a interim
study bill that I filed you know Skip no
uh meeting has been scheduled for yes
and I'm just wondering did we do intend
okay
ah see
penny
okay
Glenn actually
I believe there was for each of the yeah
reach the ones I'll take a look at the
scheduling I was yeah tied up with the
primary the interims for the co-ops is
this Thursday
um let's go down through any other
things which we have on the docket here
if I can find the schedule book here
everybody has down on the 27th the
legislative oversight committee that's
where Nate green comes in we'll be doing
the overview and try and take these
cohorts of the assessment taking them
through that's at 10 o'clock right here
excuse me it's one o'clock it's one
o'clock in the afternoon
uh pardon me on the 27th that's a uh
Tuesday
um
our
uh
the next one after that is October 4th
yes
and then we'll be meeting
a lot of these issues are all linked
and so if you're able to attend some of
these other meetings it might be wise to
try and just get a handle because I know
we will be in that shortage me looking
at the pipeline and that's extremely the
pipeline meaning post-secondary
education how that's impacting public
education availability of certification
people certification of people and and
getting more information from those
education departments
important stuff
um
the 27th that's the legislative
oversight committee
that's a statutory committee I'm not
that's that's already been scheduled but
what's going to be presented at that
might be you know Wise that you you come
and participate
um
Rick yeah if I can so so this is a a
committee actually that had been a
statutory Committee in law for a number
of years and hadn't met in a while and
then it was well it was let go it was
let go by us and then and then we
reformatted it or re did it yet we put
in a new bill this this yeah just a few
just you know this year to re-establish
this so this will be the first meeting
of of it and I think you know it like I
said it hasn't met in a while this will
become very active because it's about
Improvement and performance
of our academic standards right and and
there's a lot of activity going on right
now with Ed rules
um uh um 306.
and and so this is an area that that uh
that this statutory committee um has
so
yeah what we want to do is look at the
next time as from that was the next
thing on the dock here in the calendar
um are there any dates which are not
good for folks on on the committee here
that's
skip October 6th
okay
are you getting in any discussion on the
Medicaid
automatic identification and
implementation of meals through direct
certification but
I know it's a little off from what your
we haven't really gone anywhere with it
yeah
the New Hampshire hunger people came in
and talked to us and she mentioned
um
how much time do you need everybody to
review 1680 and really come up with some
to share some of your thoughts on
whether it contains elements or some
areas which you know we need to discuss
the specifics of the bill we need to get
down into that
so it's a couple weeks needed if that is
then we could meet that week
yeah that's open for myself
I'm going to be here the Third
and the sixth
uh
okay well it's not gonna work then
That's The Advisory Group for your
no
okay
okay so on what day
third the third
yeah that's fine
one o'clock yeah I won't be in
attendance
I will share the voicemail okay
is a Monday good for everybody
that's Labor Day in Australia
okay
pardon me
so from all my notes on 1680 right here
I'm all ready to go okay please look at
it and write stuff down because we need
to get on with it uh we're gonna have to
make a recommendation here
shortly
okay no more said thank you for coming
um it was another comment made earlier
so it's not really about to build as
much but I think um representative
Nelson said
um about the unions and they protect bag
teachers and it stings and we were
talking about the quality of teachers
and I don't think that that's actually
accurate I think
um the whole in my experience from
negotiations is that
um we negotiated teach and
differentiated teacher evaluation plans
with the whole goal of
if teachers aren't doing as well as they
should be then there's a plan put forth
how do they get better or if they don't
perform then they can release them but
there's a step so I just wanted to say
that say I think years ago maybe that
was the way it was but right now I think
we do have evaluation plans
for teachers to improve and if they
don't
then there's a consequence for that
that's all thank you and I actually one
more uh just in rep in response to uh
representative lakis uh in terms of
money and programs like even in my
district when they were trying to
address those kids and needed extra help
then they instituted the our um response
to intervention RTI and that cost money
so even in a district that has funds I
mean all of these
um there are things that these schools
do to help these kids that aren't
performing as well they do cost money so
that's all nothing's free nothing's free
thank you